oh
cool
[Music]
down myself
[Music]
[Music]
a million
[Music]
years
I guess some things are better gone but
I really miss that
is where I got to be King Kong
and the one where I'm friends with the
yeti
I was a mad scientist who made a man out
of spaghetti but if it's true
[Music]
[Music]
by my side always
and me and me and me
[Music]
oh hello hello hello hello
man The Last Goodbye Oh So topical to
this stream in so many ways that I won't
explain further until the very end of
the stream uh just make sure
you know you know really really speaks
to my current mood at the moment saying
goodbye one final time
coincidentally 10 years of me I said I
wouldn't be a part of this bit
I said I said I said to uh to Amy
yesterday like hey what if on the stream
uh tomorrow
I do this big bit through the whole
stream where I I pretend and make
Illusions and say like humming it's you
know this is a Bittersweet day
and then like
it's like make you all think that I was
gonna quit YouTube
Maybe
the Navy said like maybe not man so you
you can't keep a secret you're right
you're right so oh what a
heavy day visit
but 10 years 10 years yeah and yes I saw
a lot of people yeah I I got my hair cut
um this is the funny thing about every
time I go into a haircut when I have
longer hair
I tell them hey I'd like to keep the
length uh I kind of like it but if you
could clean it up and then they go okay
and they cut it all off and I'm like
what part of me wanting to keep the
length uh did you not understand
um but yeah so this is what happened
thanks thank you I don't hate it like
it's not like it's a bad Cub it was like
I wanted to keep it in a couple days it
needs to go yeah it needs to adjust to
it definitely am I retiring
huh
[Music]
let me get through the stream first
anyway 10 years it's not 10 years as of
today
um but it is 10 years uh as of April 4th
which was when space released uh so that
was why space released on a Monday is
because that was a very important day
for me and I wanted to be able to say
that I released my own most ambitious
project on my 10-year anniversary
because what better 10-year anniversary
than that
um so yes this is going to be talking
about 10 years of YouTube but also it's
going to be the big behind the scenes
stream for space to talk about all that
if you have not seen in space with
markiplier yet
you should probably go watch it um
because we're going to be talking about
a lot of spoilers a lot of spoilers that
are that have been uh
we've been eager to talk about for a
very long time
um but for right now uh I just want to
kick it off by saying thank you thank
you so much for being with me for those
of you who have been here 10 years which
I know there are some of you who've been
here for 10 years
um and also to any of you who have
decided to hop along for this crazy ride
uh that is my channel and the videos
that I make and especially all of it
culminating in in space
um so it's just like it's just been a
really really satisfying experience and
um was there one quote uh someone said
like I forget where was look at tweet or
something it's like Man Mark just seems
like he is entirely uh uh entirely
powered by the creative process or
something like that oh yeah yeah what
was that tweet I forget who said that
but he was like yeah you know honestly I
am and I wish a lot of people a lot more
people were
um because it's true I just love
the creative process it's hard but it's
it's super super fun so last minute
warning for spoilers on Space because
this is going to be going over
everything whole show the whole show
we're going to be talking about the
production of it we're going to be
playing it with you guys so this is your
last chance if you're here to go watch
it so you don't get everything spoiled
that being said we're gonna play through
it so you guys will be able to vote on
which way we go and then we're going to
talk about some of our favorite scenes
uh look behind the production of it
um and just like just generally anything
we want to say we also have the behind
the scenes video that's done uh made by
my lovely editors who have done an
incredible job on that
I wanted to get the blooper video ready
for today but unfortunately that won't
be ready today so the blooper and behind
the scenes video will be posted
separately uh next Sunday I'm going to
say next Sunday and also just FYI uh
after my big end of stream announcement
I'll save it for later I just uh I
couldn't possibly even contemplate that
right now uh yeah so just thank you all
so much uh for joining this I also want
to give a shout out to the people who
I've done collapse with I was I I didn't
do as many as I wanted to do because I
just so happened to go to the hospital
like two weeks ago or a week and a half
ago or whatever it was
um which kind of got in the way of doing
a lot of things like
that uh but just today like I I did a
video with uh the quarter crew talking
with Nico about this and how they were a
big inspiration for not only me starting
YouTube but also just for
um like just learning how to do these
VFX and how to execute and how to
communicate like the needs and wants of
it and also uh you know there's the
video I did with ro Rosanna Pansino
which if you haven't watched part two
yet Rose in it I will not spoil when or
where but uh just like the entire uh
realization that there's the other
people on YouTube that I've met and
worked with and maybe not work with long
the way they were more happy more than
happy to talk with me and do a video
with me the corridor video and the Row
video are bangers oh yeah oh absolutely
they're really good the Row video just
like I have only become less hinged or
insufferable
my general philosophy is whenever I'm
doing a collab I try to make the other
person look better by making me look as
bad as possible
that's my general you can do that with
Roe because like you know row so well
that she's not gonna get like offended
and think that you're not
taking it you don't care yeah
yeah so if he's just as insane as you
are oh my God maybe even more so you
know it just doesn't come across that
way on camera sometimes
uh but yeah it's really good so go find
that video uh support the corridor video
I just made a community post about that
earlier today and then upcoming I'm
doing a video where I talk with Anthony
Padilla
um and that's just like a nice it's
gonna be very long conversation if
you've seen his videos before you know
the basic format he spends a day with me
and good God we talked for like three
hours straight I think I'm pretty sure
about three hours so I don't know how
that's gonna get cut down uh but it will
all right with all that being said it is
just about time to get going on this
whole shebang uh talking about space
watching space me revealing all the
secrets that even to this day some
people have missed a lot of people have
missed some of the things that I want to
showcase connect in the dots though oh
yeah oh there's some people that like
almost nail on the head like super super
accurate like really really uh close to
the truth of the matter
um and it's just like it's really fun to
see people dive into this one and really
like eat it up tear it apart
um enjoy it because that's why I make
videos that's why I've been making
videos for 10 years is not only for me
like to feel fulfilled in what I'm doing
but also just like to see you guys enjoy
what I'm doing you know and really like
get absorbed into it gets sucked into
the Wormhole it is my mind you know all
those things
um but I guess I guess before we get
started maybe we could get a couple
questions from people if people have any
overall questions about over arching
over foreign
also like I didn't do a video with
matpat yet I I hope to in the future but
you know
matpat did like not only two streams
playing it but also just uh made a lore
video about it before part two came out
and also just this thank you to
everybody that has played in space with
markiplier either on stream or in video
that's totally okay you can do that film
your reactions to it stream it uh pull
your audience to play it I've been uh
you know supporting people to do we've
been watching all of them yeah Kick Club
has been uh kicking the the hell out of
people that do so it's very nice
it's very nice oh uh no there's no part
three my God sorry are you kidding me
there's no part three it was uh it was
uh more than enough work doing part one
and two it's a six and a half hour run
time guys six hours fifty Seven Minutes
six hours 57 minutes there are six hours
and 57 minutes of total footage in both
part one and part two I'd like to think
there's more than enough content for you
to enjoy
I love the idea of there being more but
yeah that would be great if there was if
there was more uh but you know that's
that's that's kind of like the whole
thing it's not even me being like come
on how much do you guys want I wanted to
give you more I will show you some of
the earlier drafts of uh my early even
before they were scripts like my
outlines of the show and the ideas that
I wanted how much content got cut how
many pages was the script when we
started filming God I have no idea it's
300 something I wish I had the binder
yeah it was um I think when I when I
finished it was about 120 000 words was
how much the script was okay for part
one and part two uh before I started
cutting it down actually I think I have
it up here if I open is it this one I I
don't know if this one has like me
actually writing more of the yeah
because a lot of them are just yeah this
isn't enough this isn't all of it but
even even this with uh just outline is
165 000 words
um the actual
full breadth of how much I wrote before
we got to that hundred and twenty
thousand uh I think I wrote about
250 something thousand and I don't know
if that even includes some of those like
last minute scenes that you were writing
oh yeah those editions I have no idea
like those were you know a few pages at
a time changes that we made there so the
final final I don't even know it's big
and uh like tear it apart you guys have
been enjoying it I'm thrilled with the
response to it people yeah all the all
the art and the memes and also just like
people actually feeling the story that's
really special to me and and I I can't
thank you guys enough for all of that
okay so with that being said let's get
into the first video oh oh also The Last
Goodbye by Schmo Yoho if you guys don't
send the Gregory Brothers on Spotify the
Gregory Brothers on Spotify the last
goodbye is on Spotify it's on iTunes buy
it support them they did an incredible
job I will talk about that you know the
answer see scene all of it we're gonna
go through everything today and then we
the BTS video is going to be very fun I
have not even seen it yet so there's a
lot of stuff that went on behind the
scenes that I did not see that BTS how
much footage do you think it was uh
each of them had about five to six hours
so maybe like 20 hours of behind the
scenes footage because it was six
and that's like the vast majority of
what the behind the scenes video is
and so it was just Tyler with a camera
for like six weeks straight like eight
hours a day of filming a lot of people
on set just like with their phones like
grabbing stuff it's super cool yeah it's
uh there's so many things that I could
talk about we'll try to keep it
condensed I actually wrote notes for
this stream so we don't get too off
topic and go crazy because otherwise we
could be here all day we will be here we
will be here all day uh so without
further Ado
this is
in space with markiplier part one
spoiler alert everything will be spoiled
and we will be stopping and starting the
most through this and then we will be
voting on uh different choices
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you might want to take a step back there
again
so I want to pause it right here
um to give a shout out to this man hold
Boggs incredible actor there's actually
a short film that I uh helped produce
like all I did was I helped fund it
um just because he had this idea if you
haven't seen it it's called crazy I
believe it's on YouTube I think it is
yeah so if you look up like crazy short
film or crazy movie and you see old bugs
this guy is pretty fun I'm in it just
for a little bit but I'm in it
um but also just like to talk about the
fact that this show looks good
period uh it it was so nice to be able
to do this because the problem with
doing things in space is obviously I
can't go to space so you have to rely on
VFX for all of it you do um and this is
what I talked about with court or crew
the reason like it turned out as good as
it did with six hours and 57 minutes of
run time and over 400 VFX shots and if
you don't know what that means that's
okay those of you that do your jaws are
on the floor
um I think it amounted to like 460 VFX
shots uh maybe more
um and it's just like
the reason that it was able to happen is
not only because the people that worked
on it were incredibly talented burning
tractor in Austin uh incredibly talented
people if anyone in the film industry is
watching this they are worth the higher
because they do great work and they're
really fun to work with big shout out to
West and his entire team for doing this
but the reason I talk Corridor about
this and I have to give them
appreciation is because they
have a series called VFX artists react
and it's a very entertaining series I
highly recommend anybody watch it
because they watch movies and they break
down the process behind visual effects
and they talk about how it's done where
things can go wrong and what that did it
didn't teach me how to do visual effects
but it taught me uh the language of
visual effects and knowing the
constraints that you operate in with
visual effects it's not magic it's art
people have to actually work on it so
with this you have this is a very
complex shot this might be the most
complex shot of the show although there
are many because of all the elements you
have in the background those windows
it's just green screen and tracking
markers on there and they comped in they
built this beautiful ship they built
like these windows there all these
different elements combined to a
relatively seamless experience that
really immerse you in this space it
makes you feel like you are in space
um so it's just like it's really cool to
see all this come together it in these
every single second of this opening
scene took hours of work I just want to
put that out there all right continuing
I'm sorry I know I'm staring a lot huge
fan kid fan but find your career for
quite a while now
invisible Tower this is Philip marmota
pushing Docking Bay four
closing the blast Shields
copy you waldermore truth be told we
couldn't afford to show that anyway but
uh yeah don't get me wrong I know
exactly where we're at check it out
we're gonna land in five
captain we're here early
because it's an honor
you know I think maybe uh we can hang
out or something go get a cupboard you
know Beer's cool
welcome aboard the Invincible
I need to go back a bit okay
so pausing again here because I said
this a few times here and there
um for those of you who have watched
this and remember this is big spoilers
if you have not seen the Show links are
in the description to both part one and
part two it actually doesn't matter
which part you start on
um go down there pick flip a coin pick
one watch the show we're talking about
everything here you can come back later
the Vaude of this will be posted and all
that but the reason I'm backing up is
because I said
in small circles that for those of you
who have watched actually let me just
say
in chat right now
for this opening video
did you see old mark
I want to see in chat if you saw old
Mark in this video oh yeah captions
right
so while people say that I want to just
point out because I saw people asking
you know how Mark's logo says like m2702
which is like obviously just a joke
reference and people were like oh where
the other patches on the other
characters references
um and I think most of them are just the
costume people putting like their
favorite little numbers or things in
them yeah so they're meaningful to the
crew yeah but there isn't like a code or
anything in there this is like one of
the longer running jokes jokes I say
jokes your light isn't on oh no oh
this was a constant plague this this
risk computer thing had these lights on
it and it was a constant battle because
we had to turn it off to save battery
because it lasted like no time and I
would always forget to turn it back on
there's a couple places I didn't realize
it was right I didn't realize it was
here either oh man
okay anyway so some of most of you saw
Mark some of you didn't now tell me this
did Mark old Mark appear in the opening
video Once
or twice
that's the next question before I spy it
is like I Spy
okay
once twice once twice a lot of onces
a lot of once is
the correct answer
is three times
this is old mark
right there
you can barely see him
but that my friends
is old Mark Bubba buoy
and there's a reason for this there's a
reason
that he's here right and once again
we'll get to it when we get to Old Mark
but there's a reason this is the first
time that he appears
you know like old Mark you can see the
blue sweater like you you can tell
that's him he goes into the elevator
before you and you'll actually notice
the door closes back there as he goes up
and that's why it took you long enough
but let me give you the grand tour
before we embark
about this room
oh yeah
right yeah
um so this is the another behind the
scenes little look into this this room
that we're in
um this is the hangar quote unquote uh
same room as the warp core room so we
did this is like the practicality of
filming and the limitations of what we
had we have a lot of limitations that we
had to work with we only had so big of a
set so we had to be really smart about
how we approach doing this it wasn't
even that we had so big of a set we had
so big of a Sound Stage that the set was
built on our set
literally touched like the um what do
you call that like the fire the fire
line right or you need like the five
feet or whatever of space between the
set and the wall in case there's a fire
yeah actually we were over the line
initially because the dimensions that we
were given were incorrect yeah for the
build of the ship so it's like you only
have so much I mean how big was the
whole ship I mean whole ship I would
guess it was maybe like probably like a
maybe 30 by 40 feet yeah 30 feet by 40.
it might be like 60. yeah maybe it's
it's hard to say I have the the
schematic but I don't know the exact
dimensions but not as big as it looks
and that's the illusion that we had to
do yes thank you for all the 10 years it
is uh not 10 years as of today but still
10 years yeah it's still 10 years yeah
it's the first time I've actually been
able to celebrate it this entire time
um but yeah let's continue this is my
pride and joy my baby well more baby I
guess now
but I made her and the baby will always
remember
her father
can I also talk about something here
um so as many of you know the computer
is voiced by uh the narrator of
kurtzgesocked his name is Steve Taylor
uh there was actually supposed to be
more kurz gazagt uh integration here but
uh the the Creator I forget his name
oh man that's that's bad for me uh
kurska sagged himself Mr
um we were actually going to have more
integration here this this uh computer
pad was actually supposed to have one of
the little little in a nutshell birds
come in there and the computer was
supposed to talk through them but
scheduling like getting all that in time
it all it fell through a little bit
um they're busier than you are
absolutely crank it out that was
extremely high he was busy writing the
immune book which I do have
um which is like a like a college
textbook level book
um really really cool stuff but but it's
like this whole show will will probably
not touch on all of it we'll talk talk a
lot about compromises improvisation
things that we want versus what we can
actually do that's the nature of any
film unless you're Marvel or Disney and
you can just throw money at the problem
until you think the problem is so that
doesn't fix the problem that doesn't fix
the problem so uh so so a lot of the
show like I'm super proud of every
single second of this show but it also
every single second of it because it's
my show and our show and like I wanted
it to be the best it possible it could
be so it's like present during every
single moment of it and like planning it
out and thinking of Solutions on your
feet all make for a better show so
anyway we get in the LA welcome aboard
captain and head engineering prepare
full sterilization
first stop the warp core the heart and
soul of the ship still not 100 sure how
it works but this is the same room we
just walked this is the hangar right so
it's the same exact dimensions of the
room we just do a magic trick where we
go in it's actually to take those
pillars along the wall we sliced them
down the middle flipped the one upside
down put the lights behind it and if you
think about it like planning when we
film something is important because if
we didn't get all the hanger stuff that
we needed we no longer had that
literally destroyed pieces of it to make
the next portion of so scheduling when
we film things was incredibly difficult
the cryopods were the biggest part of
that the cryopods we had to move them
around because we only had the two but
the cryopod as you'll find out is also
in the cryo room one in the cryo room
two in the the main the bridge the
bridge thank you so every time you had
to move it and they're made of foam so
they get damaged every single time you
move it so if you pay attention you can
see that they're like banged up on the
corners because you had to physically
lift this massive build bring it around
the entire building and stick it in
another room exactly it was a challenge
a logistical challenge but all of it
like it it worked towards the purpose of
making a better show so it's not with
enough planning and honestly there could
have been more planning it was there but
anyway anyone see something oh look at
that
old Mark could that possibly be old Mark
what this is probably the one that
people noticed second because it's the
second most obvious one the first one is
not obvious that's intentional but this
is the second most so there he is
there's our boy
an old Mark is here and it's important
to note
old Mark is here
something goes wrong in this room right
okay this is where the spoilers are
coming in if you haven't seen the show
watch the show hey look not bad anyway
sure how it works but you don't need to
know how something works in order to use
it
and when we found it again it passed
every safety test with flying colors
it's not going to be like last time
this time the Invincible is finally
gonna live up to her name but just in
case
I built in a special precaution if
anything goes wrong we can detonate
these explosives and separate the warp
core from the rest of the ship
I've yet to meet a problem that can't be
solved with explosives and speaking of
explosives the main reactor turns out
you pretty much need the power of a star
to tear up in a wormhole so a star I
built built like a tank too
well pause it here yes someone did just
yell my eyes that was uh I believe that
was will that was will uh who if you
remember from Heist
um one of the fun things in in Heist you
are it's during the uh the dark path
where I keep going like let's split up
and if you handcuff me and the last one
and you're chased by those cultists it's
the entire crew that we film with uh
actually chanting in the same building
that we're filming this one is going
Intruders but also they chant we are
evil we will kill you
um but uh a lot of times when we're
doing the post-production we'll need
like a voice for something like uh
that's actually Carlos who gets less in
the eyes
um and he goes you know so we had will
the producer
um who like if you don't know what
producers do it's almost impossible to
explain uh but shows would not happen
without producers I'll just leave it at
that so he he goes my eyes but also in
Heist he's the one the last cultist to
fall down go who goes Intruders and then
gets his head like caved in on one of
those Pisces Intruders clunk that's also
will that's why there's like random like
my voice is in at one part yeah during
these sound mixes and it's like it's not
like you have the actors there still and
it doesn't matter whose voices is you're
like oh like this part's quiet so we
need a line here and so we just throw
whoever's there up and it's kind of fun
because then there's like these little
Easter eggs of the crew doing voices and
the producers yeah it's really fun
someone someone noticed uh there's
underneath my RR webcam right here
there's this dancing dude uh that is if
you didn't notice right right there I
care webcam kind of obscures it but he's
he's there pretty much the whole time
tear up in a wormhole so a star
felt like a tank too
so there's a lot of little things that
the VFX team just put in like that uh
because you know they're building a
reactor and they're like let's put
something fun in there that's what the
beauty of this show is like people had
fun it was a lot of hard work don't get
me wrong it was a lot of hard work but
it was also fun and to me that should be
the point of the creative process it
should be fun but that's just a little
Easter egg that's not old marker I think
excuse me maybe you do
Kevin
or
yeah it's Bert he makes sure that the
ship don't go boom next up is cryo
I want to give a shout out to uh this is
Carlos
um who he was in Heist too he was in
Heist as well some of the the extras we
well I mean they are extras designated
extras but they were basically crew here
because I had them do so much more than
just like an extra there's like donut
crew yeah crew member actor crew member
not crew like yeah exactly it's hard
there's a lot of like rules and
regulations with like determining extras
versus crew speaking rules versus
non-speaking rules to me they're part of
the the ship's crew and so I had them do
a lot more
um and pay them equivalently to do a lot
more
um and also just like I'm so grateful
that they were a part of it this is a
running joke through the whole show as
you'll notice I'm borrowing a few
exceptions which we'll point out
um where he is ever since this moment
constantly injured no matter where he is
he's in church which is just so goddamn
funny and also Bob is Bert you know just
like oh so grateful that Bob played that
role all the main crew when you wrote
the show initially
um
casting in mind when you wrote it did
you no not really
um actually I think um Mick maybe Mick
kind of actually I was kind of wondering
about Gunther I thought maybe Gunther
could have been
um uh map hat actually I had a thought I
didn't know that I had an idea for that
but you know I didn't really have any
solid idea until the character until I
started writing the dialogue of the
characters which never comes first for
me unless it's like a specific line that
I want to do
um I don't know who's gonna play it and
then the Gunther as he like transitioned
because Gunther
uh there was there was actually like
Gunther begun in the earliest draft it
was a there was two choices that don't
exist in the show there was um wake the
pilot wake the Gunner to deal with the
same problem and one of them was like
Peter p pilotson and the other was
Gunther b Gunnerson those were the two
like
two people that you wake up and uh so
originally Gunther was not a part of the
main tree of crew there was no main Trio
of crew before you could talk for 10
hours about just this first fixing the
ship section of the show because that
probably went through the most changes
it really did that's fine uh it
definitely went through the most changes
it was definitely the most that was like
the logistically most complex about like
how the hell do you absolutely I don't
know
the literally the first half of part one
was three weeks of our entire film shoot
was just the first half of part one and
anything on the ship was the first uh 18
days of filming was on this ship that's
how much uh how involved it was and how
how intensive it was to get all these
details together and also while we were
filming we were also still building the
set we were filming as we were building
it was it's crazy though it's crazy that
this managed to happen it's crazy that
any like film with a decent budget gets
made with like a full-size crew yeah
it's insane that anything ever gets done
it's it really this whole shoot and like
this shoot went really well like as far
as having like problems on the fly like
it was very straightforward it went well
but even so the entire time it feels
like
every day is like this is not gonna
happen like this is not gonna happen
like yeah cause there's always you're
like directing for you and and producing
in the you know the kind of management
side of it the whole time you're just
like making concessions and you're
you're like okay well we gotta like this
actor's injured so we have to do
something we have to change the schedule
somehow like I don't know it's just
shocking that anything gets made yeah oh
uh some people were asking why is he
injured uh you will recognize him
because he
is right here maybe the grand tour
before uh you you hit him with your ship
captain
what do you mean why is he injured he
just took a shuttle to the face it's a
wonder he's not just injured
anyway yeah pay attention come on pay
attention I think that's perfectly clear
no it's not that well that's that's why
like a lot of these things in the show I
don't shove in your face and be like
this is it there's a lot of things that
exist in the background
um and it was intentional because with
Heist I wanted a lot more things going
on in the background
uh and so um
with with this one I wanted it to not
only be like the world is moving around
the captain things move very quick but
things are constantly happening in the
background as well and it was something
that like with a little more time in
film we were able to do anyway we're
we're getting bogged down here no no no
not you it's them it's their fault it's
all your fault
full Captain you did this
the colonists are prepped stable and
ready for transit systems are working at
110 percent too which is a little weird
but Overkill never hurts trust me you do
not want to be awake when the warp core
hits the gas
so uh a few things to talk about this
this is obviously a set extension and if
you'll notice that uh from this moment
on we see this and it establishes the
scale of the ship this with the reactor
and the ceiling in the warp core room
um it uses a VFX to build the ship out
and make it bigger but also we shut it
and never see it again because that's
expensive so that's like the the joy and
the charm of doing this on YouTube you
know and like not for like a streaming
service a different streaming service
it's like the campiness of this can be
the joke you can get away with that yeah
exactly like we show it once and then we
never see it again I mean that can be
funny and that can be like part of the
charm of the show yeah absolutely but
honestly I think other shows could get
away oh yeah they're just not a comedy
you can really do it with comedy yeah
they're not brave enough
uh also this is Dorian talking here
let's get them there safe oh don't worry
before they know it they're going to
wake up at the side of a brand new
planet with a fresh cup of coffee in
their hands why don't you give them more
windows to look through well maybe I
will
maybe then someone might appreciate the
Aesthetics yeah
what could go wrong with a crew like
this
good to go don't worry cap no asteroids
Getting By Me You can count on that
handsome and her beautiful
it wasn't yeah
this this is the old Mark that most
people noticed
um
right there that's old Mark uh
uh the the whole point of this is like
not only to give like life to the ship
and stuff but also it's like that video
with um what I wanted all this to be
it's like that video where you know the
two teams playing basketball oh and they
ask you to count how many times the like
red team passes or whatever team it was
um and you're so focused on the
basketball and counting that that you
don't notice a dancing bear literally
break dancing through the video that's
the point of this is just to give a
light to the ship but also hide the fact
that there's a freaking old man hobbling
out like you get bumped two and two and
you get someone staring at you with
psychologically speaking I wish uh this
had like who was it that showed the
video of the eye tracker for audiences
watching a movie did you see that oh um
they showed us out of the sound mix yeah
yeah and it was just like this idea that
they they tracked the eyes of people
watching this so it's like I would love
to know where people's eyes are here
and then oh no Captain I'm falling catch
me taking this ball like 10 times
navigation
things are looking good Captain life
support is online unless it's not and
then we wouldn't know until we passed
out
seems fine everything is accounted for
ready to see our new home all that's
left now
foreign
try not to get them too excited Captain
I know how your speeches can get people
riled up
she was not very good
no
honestly
we only got one pick you see how Tyler's
has to keep a hand on her because this
is the problem right getting everybody
on set on one day is a logistical
difficulty right so getting all these
people with these different schedules
here all at once filming is planning
making anything is planning you have to
have a good plan and be able to execute
on this plan so literally we have all
these people it takes time to get
everyone in their place it takes time to
talk to each of one of them and explain
what their actions are
yeah three hours oh yeah this in this
hallway we did the same day it's tough
uh and Chica kept
screwing up the shot by running out
early so Tyler was just like I'll just
I'll just keep a hand on her to make
sure that she doesn't run away I think
she was just so over stimulated it was a
lot it was like it's just very happy
much too excited is the problem because
she's just like oh boy what's going on
there's a lot and then I think Amy
you're right here yeah I'm off camera so
I'm right there and then I call her and
that's when she should leave with
everyone else but as soon as I she would
stay and then as soon as I was out of
line of sight she would run off she'd
forget what was happening yeah exactly
but because of the placement of the
camera I couldn't always be in line of
sight
so she would just she's a diva right
she's just a diva so
no she's probably the the single biggest
mood booster on set oh yeah people being
able to go into the um the production
room and where chica was yeah we didn't
have them on set when we were on
location but when we were filming on the
Sound Stage yeah um we had them with us
which was a delight you know it was a
delay everyone being able to go back
there and just pet chicka chicka chicka
loved it of course I was always worried
that she would be so we had really
intense covid testing protocols right
that was the other challenge yeah which
is like you know an expensive part of
the production but also like took up a
good half hour every Monday morning and
yeah it was just like that was a big
part of it but and everyone had to be
masked the whole time you know there's
Union rules about all of this and the
original YouTube deal like had all these
rules in them which is great and no one
got sick like we were filming at the
height of like the second wave in Texas
like it was scary
um but I was always worried that chica
was gonna be like the super spreader
event because people would come in and
they'd like lower their mask and they'd
give her a little kiss on the forehead
but everyone would keep kissing her on
the forehead and patner you had this
brilliant idea you know the Saint
Bernard like barrel of rum that is under
a Saint Bernard's neck you bought one
and a giant bottle of hand sanitizer and
it was going to be a thing where you
modified it so that she was wearing this
big thing of hand sanitizer so people
would have to like sanitize it you've
been too busy I didn't get a chance to
put it together and also like the test
testing it out chica did not like it I
don't know
so anyway it was actually not just
Monday it was Monday Wednesday Friday
yeah it was three times a week we were
tested uh uh first thing in the morning
nothing wakes you up like a swab up your
nose bam
and Fridays were the the the Deep nose
uh swap so like Monday Wednesday was
like front of no swab and then Friday
was the brain scratcher
but when you're getting on a set at like
5 a.m you're like all right like yeah
that really does wake you up huh
anyways
I'm sure you'll make a great speech once
we get ready different totally different
days right so I wonder look at your hair
we could probably see yes
it's hard to say yeah so this is a this
is shade
this is a transition you can actually
probably see it uh it's really well done
so this is uh probably where they
transition to shot B I probably think
they put like a feather thing or
actually probably in the middle because
it was it was it was Danny before and
then Tyler wearing this costume
afterwards because about the same height
and then this is just a different day so
pretty smooth transition I'd say that's
a good one yeah anyway
I'm sure you'll make a great speech
twice it was mine and oh no right I had
to Chuck oh and I forgot the magic it's
not a problem of course but just before
you go to sleep be absolutely sure do
not well opening at ten nine
eight
seven
six
spring error
[Music]
a software update is available restart
to apply this update
software update complete good morning
Captain we are currently error he is
into our journey coffee is on Route
current ship station
absolutely catastrophic
protocol
that was tough yeah
yeah
Reviving head engineering
oh
so you don't care
too far on the bridge
automatic fire suppression system
offline air
safe offline
um okay so we just saw a lot right
people are asking do not what and that's
I'll tell you straight up that's just a
generic joke right that's a cliche in
storytelling where right before you do
something something tells you be sure to
not and then they're cut off it's like
the the the gorilla the chocolate
gorilla melting in the pot of milk it's
like quickly I don't have enough time
before I go you absolutely must you know
that's that's that joke there's nothing
to that however there are uh some things
here to note
um specifically a lot of people ask uh
who says this right who says don't give
up that's Doreen
I'll explain why later
some of you already probably know reason
why but I'll explain why later
um this uh electricity on the finger is
important to remember because it's
context clues for later on
um this me flopping out very fun
you did a 3D body scan I did it they
brought a truck that had like hundreds
of cameras in it yeah yeah you just
stood there t-pose yeah I talked about
that with the corridor guys because
their videos were one of the things was
like maybe we can get this ahead of time
and have we had one day this is where
planning comes in one day to get all the
3D scans and we did that I went through
multiple costume changes just for that
and we stacked those costume changes
with like green screen stuff that we
needed it's all planning it's all
difficult but one of the things that was
important to the story that has existed
since the beginning of my first
iteration of this show was that the
first choice would be made without me
um and that was always the case because
one of the things like I love Heist I
got nothing against Heist or date but
the problem that those those uh videos
as fun as they are represent is you
don't have much agency in terms of the
adventure and it's it's very countered
the idea that you are the captain of the
ship you are in charge you make the
decisions
Vlog Captain here walks make decision
walk say open door you know
um so the first choice I always died
before anything happened I think the
first generation I was knocked out yeah
and you had to do something without me
but I loved the idea that you are so
used to me guiding you through these
Adventures that I'm taking myself out of
the equation literally
it's such a beautiful it's so cool it's
so sudden it's so I almost didn't want
to use that in the trailer because I
wanted to to be even more sudden but
yeah you are alone in this and with that
being said we are at our first decision
they could use the paddles
yeah yeah we're gonna get the poll in
here
um
no no no
put out the fire or fix life
support again heavy spoilers if you're
just joining this and you won't see it
for yourself go watch it but also you
can join us
what do while they're doing that just
like men we could talk endlessly about
this room and like the TV screens and
trying to pre-plan stuff to have on
there versus sometimes the screens
um had graphics on them while we were
filming and sometimes the screens were
comped afterwards
um and you can kind of tell if you pay
attention that they're not you know yeah
normally yeah these are all before these
were already on the screen because we
had like little uh
little like tiny devices that helped us
do uh what we needed to do
all right fixed life support seems to be
the way that people want to go
wise wise decisions wise Maybe
good morning
you came the captain runs
so I know where you're gonna say Okay
YouTube was incredibly supportive of
this show incredibly supportive like
Marquette full creative control they
were wonderful they did not think this
was funny
they were like can you take that out and
we're like well no we already filmed it
we can't just
remove the hands
because like even in all these things in
Heist and whatnot this has been a part
in day like we've done our best to like
it was one hand when we only had one
hand but like this has been a part of it
for a while just like weird chopping
running it's like that's kind of like it
doesn't make sense but we like it it's
cute
uh so yeah YouTube they had a few notes
like that one of which will infuriate
you we'll get to that when we get it but
thankfully
I did have complete creative control
which is rare in YouTube originals and
really like I do gotta thank you for
trusting me with that that was one of my
contingencies for heist of even doing
heist in the first place was like I need
full creative control I will not do
something without it which is why you
were able to make something we had a
long conversation about this the other
night make something that wasn't like
Heist 2 that wasn't just like like
branching out you're like okay I want to
do this more narrative thing and it's
riskier and Incredibly complicated but
because you had creative control they
were like okay yeah like they trusted
you to do it they should have gave them
something good before they're like all
right and I told them like this will be
good it'll be different but it will be
good because this is what I wanted to do
anyway continuing
to unsafe levels
[Music]
foreign
oxygen levels Rising good news Captain
the momentary lapse in oxygen
extinguished the fire on the bridge
for impact
Ed let's try defenses
object the Asteroid Defense system is
working at 100 efficient
City corporations you are feeling
uncertain the guns working to keep you
safe
I said the Asteroid Defense System is
fine
oh my God yeah okay so I'm gonna put up
a new poll
um
and and we reserved the right to
overrule if we get we need to show you
something that needs to be shown but for
now I'm gonna do this bull
um one thing that's gonna like blow your
mind and just talk about the iterative
process of writing this is um originally
and a lot of people have pointed out
like okay if you fix a lot of people
Justified if you fix life support
logically that would increase the oxygen
then the fire would grow and you're
right you're absolutely 100 right
um I hand waived it with okay the oxygen
ran out and that extinguished the fire
which wouldn't necessarily be the case
the original incarnation of this show is
both choices putting out the fire or
fixing life support ended with your
death because you couldn't solve it by
yourself that was like the whole Crux of
the issue it was supposed to be an
educational moment to show you that the
the respawn mechanic however
in the differentiating of making this
first thing it was too big to have too
many fail States because the difference
between this and Heist is there are no
fail states there are failures yes but
the story continues it continues to
Branch it continues to Branch so if you
have two deaths initially that's an
entire exponential more number of videos
that you go through and this first
section of saving the ship is so many
videos already uh that I had to pare it
down and I thought of a justification
reason like okay it might be fun if
there is a path a perfect path where you
as the captain can go through this
without uh ever dying but then you die
of old lady of old age later so like it
all gets you eventually but
um so yeah that was the original it
originally was going to be if you fix
the oxygen the fire grows and it goes
bigger and the whole ship explodes if
you put out the fire obviously that
thing happens so anyway wake the crew by
57
. there's still so many uh there's
errors in here that I have not gotten to
fixing yet so
foreign
I've been through hundreds of battles
fought through hundreds of traps few
Rogue drones ain't gonna get the best of
me
Asteroid Defense System online from Sean
cap
next time
give me a challenge
you feel that
it's getting kind of cold in here a lot
coolant leak in cryo uh that is no good
Captain uh I I gotta go check on ads
good luck with that
stasis temperatures continue to rise
manual intervention is required captain
okay so number one Gunther played by
Mick who was the detective in who killed
Markiplier and other things
um incredibly talented actor in general
animator voice actor like just just an
incredibly talented man a talented human
being across the board uh I'm gonna make
the pull of the inside this uh what do
call for backup
wake the crew
um yeah a lot of these choices are like
based on rules of Threes you can do the
same thing three times and that usually
will get you to a good thing unless
you're throw you're fixing it from the
outside
it doesn't work as well
for you
um but uh one of the things I'd like to
talk about this is like the the
scheduling it it is not apparent just
how difficult it is to schedule these
things in terms of uh
filming especially when we have so many
pieces in the same place and making sure
that not everything is forgotten
um like you get all the coverage you
need because you are that's the
complexity of this opening sequence on
the ship you are looking at this door
here after Gunther walks out Gunther
that gets replaced by Doreen me going in
by myself you throwing Me In from
respawning from fixing it outside you
throwing me in again when responding me
from fixing it from the outside and then
all the intros and outros the cuts
between me throwing my own dummy against
the wall you have there's probably like
12 or so iterations of just and you're
trying to match these to each other
exactly yeah all of these different
elements like this here is a cut to a
different scene this one you can
actually see it's covered up by the
explosion pretty well but you can see
this is a different scene you you look
down from the explosion and then about
right here it switches right actually
yeah I think this switches because you
can see it's like I think it's which is
just about
there ish or maybe on the way back up
I can't even remember
it's so good it's so smooth
but these are different takes oh here it
is you can see the blend here on the
motion blur here uh this is where it
Blends the shot together and then
suddenly you're looking at the other
shot because it took an hour and a half
to get Gunther all dirtied up that's the
thing about production it takes time to
do anything to we had to take one of
these and make this damage version we
had to put smoke in it we had like
like this is the only time he's damaged
like this but because the story requires
it he solved in there and then we
planned for it we had to take the time
to do that that was a big thing with
like old Mark and Frozen Mark
um and anyone who's like damaged at any
point like lady those costume changes
whatever you want to call them take a
couple hours yeah it does so that's like
and Mark directing like that's two hours
without Mark yeah Mark's sitting in a
chair so like you need to do something
with those two hours and like that's
where it gets really and that was why it
was valuable yeah you there Isaac
like the reason when we're like oh
there's 12 different versions of this
shot Isaac is the one who went through
and
who made sure we got those 12 shots and
figured out how the hell we were gonna
get those 12 shots yeah like let alone
accounting for all of like the actors
like travel schedules coming into Texas
and like making sure they weren't there
for a month it was like okay we need
them these two exact days like
the logistics behind it and that's what
producers and assistant directors do
Isaac was the first assistant director
and it is your mini Markiplier film
school here write this down kids uh I
did not go to film school so uh it's
amazing that this even happened uh
considering that you don't need it I did
it you don't need it just a heads up uh
but yeah that's a testament to YouTube
and just the creative process like I
never went to film school I did a lot of
film projects I've made many uh many
many many many many videos and many uh
sketches and stuff like that so I've
learned a lot it's not just like you
just pick up you can't just like decide
one day to do this without any
experience it won't work I'm sorry even
if you can see how you've built up the
knowledge exactly it's a build up over
time Isaac is the first assistant
director the first assistant director
not only typically sometimes it depends
on the director calls for Action calls
for cut is talking to everybody is
communicating with the rest of the crew
is like the liaison from the director to
the rest of the crew but also sets the
schedule when we film things works with
the producers to know what locations we
have what segments the shot list you
know typically uh not always like
everything's an exception but typically
that's the assistant director's job and
there's a second ad and sometimes a
third ad
um and all of them are to assist the
director in executing their vision and
that's pretty much the entire crew the
vision is this word they use for the
what the stupid [ __ ] that's in the
director's
header yesterday
or a video that you're in where they're
like are all directors doing the same
thing yeah from Corridor yeah so I think
this is what a director does what I'm
doing if you haven't seen that Corridor
crew very good but just so many pieces
and so even here we were looking at this
store like 10 different times 10 from
different iterations the Frozen mark
look probably second only to Old Mark in
terms of time Frozen Mark's my favorite
my absolute favorite Amy's favorite yeah
wake the
at least
if design caused a problem again Captain
how are you so idiot anyway
let me guess he found out the hard way
that glass windows and space don't
exactly mix
I tried to warn him but you know how
Mark is
honestly it's probably better this way
someone has to put the lives of the
colonists first and it looks like it's
gonna be me as usual I got it
hello Captain come quick
warning Colin is just safe but we got
bigger problems
I was saying computer I need you to wake
up and get him down here right now I'm
sorry but the wakey wakey protocol can
only be authorized by the captain and
head engineer well
me a promotion I'm sorry but the
previous head engineer has assigned you
the lifetime ship role of
which does not allow for direct
promotion or any upward Mobility [ __ ]
Captain I need you to wake up Bert get
him down here to fix that reactor right
now recruit with the role of us are not
allowed to make demands of the captive
we
so obviously this is Pam everyone Round
of Applause for Pam I believe Pam is in
chat right now so Pam can see everything
that you write so you better say nice
things
uh I'm gonna get the pull up but while
we do this
um poor Pam poor Pam in that goddamn
costume Pam
I know uh go ahead and tell them about
like that costume I mean it's it's a ski
suit and we're on a set that's like
there's no airflow so it's like 90
degrees in there it's hot
in summer in Texas like it's rough yeah
this is one of the things where you
write something story wise head of cryo
cryo cold of course they'd wear a snow
suit like super cute love the look great
look
miserable to wear I felt so bad we were
shoving ice packs down the costume and
it is legitimately a snow suit like it
is a heavy winter suit
oops
um but just like incredible job oh also
it was Pam's birthday just recently so
yeah wish a happy birthday there
um so
so I'm gonna
I'm gonna make a executive decision they
want to wake the crew
well actually I want to go this other
path because it is it is one of the
least viewed paths in all of part one
okay yeah it is and I I can I I would
love to go wake the crew this is the
beauty of uh interactive you can go play
for yourself if you want something
different we are gonna blow it up before
it blows you up because that's what I
want to do I'm the chaotic Captain here
I'm in charge it's me but it makes sense
that people wouldn't have clicked it
because if you've already woken the crew
twice of course you're gonna do it a
third time yeah
continue no no no no it's absolutely
right yeah because that's that's the
thing about like doing some three times
in a row same with fixing it from the
outside I wanted people to have that
option but also kind of have a little
chaos in here we're gonna blow it up
no
give me that
thank you
it's nice serving with you
software update complete good morning
Captain we are currently error years
into our journey coffee is on route to
current ship status is protocol
Captain Captain something is very wrong
yeah the life support is gonna fail
alert live scores
but it feels like I've been here before
it's a dream
stage of who I don't know I am in the
ads is gonna go hey yes
you see we're stuck in some kind of time
or something and what's weirder is I
feel like I fixed all these before
everything I've done already
when I try to get to the warp core I
can't get to the warp core because
there's a giant wormhole in the middle
of our ship which is impossible
which means that if I'm seeing it I must
be crazy but I'm not crazy you saw I
knew
but maybe I have to be crazy to be
thinking like this
like is this a dream
are we dead
I don't know
but you believe me right
Captain you believe me
okay
so this is the reason I want to go down
here because it's fun right the the what
I wanted to illustrate with the on the
ship saving stuff is number one have a
path for you to fix it without dying you
never really encounter any anomalies any
alternate universes you don't go
anywhere and then I also wanted options
for it to go Bonkers insane and it does
in a few different ones one I want to go
back to is the uh everything's fine the
Universe
um but this is uh okay what do uh I
believe you is this must be a dream
uh and and so this is like the first
Peak for Mark pre Mark going into the
Wormhole starting to question the nature
of reality and and it's it's interesting
because here you have this situation
where this is the first time if this is
your first playthrough a lot of this
show is based on what is your first
path
that is your Canon path every one of you
has a different Canon path the point of
this show is to always keep moving
forward no matter what you do your first
choices is your first path
um and that is solidified uh but with
Mark here this is your first time dying
if this is the way you win the first
time and therefore you didn't respawn
yet you haven't died yet and yet here
Mark is going like what the [ __ ] is
going on something's not right it really
does offer this kind of neat interesting
Peak behind it uh I believe you
they believe them well that's boring why
don't you let him
let him ride them because it's my 10
year
and this is actually the least picked
video in the entirety of part one this
must be a dream it has not been picked I
don't know whether because I was so
convincing whether people suspect that
something is going on this is the least
picked path of all
videos in part one it's fascinating it's
fascinating so I am overruling you
yeah ignore the boring people yeah yeah
yeah I will ignore the boring people
we're here to have fun
this is the fun path
all right pull over
no Captain
everything's real you have to believe me
Captain it's real this is real
well this stream was certainly taking
some interesting turns and what a dream
it's been so far be it from you to end
it prematurely you watch with Glee as
Mark runs frantically to and from fixing
various problems that seem to be
plaguing your ship he
'd warped core hallway to observe the
swirling miasma of chaotic Madness that
blocks the path to the Warped corn you
hear his desperate pleas that something
has gone horribly wrong with reality and
laugh even harder than before you're
still laughing while Mark activates the
Event Horizon protocol that will blow up
the warp core hallway and send the ship
sailing off into the void eager to see
where this dream is going to take you
next you wave goodbye to the swirling
blue Wormhole your ship dressed for a
while but as with most dreams things
shift pretty quickly you stumble across
an alien an alien what a dream they make
contact by immediately boarding your
ship and taking every single crew member
and colonists on board as their
prisoners apparently they're alien
poachers who are on the hunt for fresh
blood for their Gladiator pits you go
along with them for the fun of it and
are swiftly brought to some sort of
desert planet
to the waiting rooms below the fighting
pits a crowd Roars Out For Blood
somewhere above you screams rising and
falling with the fight currently taking
place someone must have won or lost as
the crowd explodes in cheers shaking the
walls of the cell Youth and placed in or
something like that what a vivid dream
while the rest of the crew we saw sobs
or bags or does some combination of the
three you find yourself idly perusing
the weapons that have been laid out
before you eventually
to drag you to the pits but they needn't
bother you already know how the fight
will go and step out onto the Sands of
your own volition it's your dream after
all your opponent is huge a great muscle
Beast Bellows out a challenge that
shakes the foundation of the Arena his
enormous weapon dripping with the fresh
blood of his previous and apparently
pervious opponents time seems to slow
down as the ax whistles towards your
journey and you find yourself smiling
people usually wake up from a dream
right before dying and to be perfectly
honest this particular dream was getting
a little
that's a good one that was a good one
your editors uh did these montages yes
this one was Marcus I believe
um so yeah that's uh in space part one
well done how many people because you
saw a couple comments
only watch to this point more than you'd
think
some people do it some people who
watched part one never went any farther
than this moment and I know some of you
watching this
might have your minds blown right now to
know that there is more show after this
so many people not a lot I'm not gonna
say it's a lot but so many more than you
would expect only got up to this point
and thought it was like Heist and been
like I got an ending and then they used
the back button to go all the way to the
top
it is not a not thousands I don't think
but there are definitely some people
that only got this far and there's an
entire but that's the point of these
that's the point of these right these
are supposed to look and they are
functionally identical to the heist
endings because that was the whole point
of the first section of part one is to
give the illusion that you're reaching a
conclusion because why else would you
think that this this is one of the more
fun ones in that you think it's a dream
because of course this can't be real I
didn't just die
you can't do that of course and then
it's just like all these all these
choices are committing to the choice as
far as it'll go that was the fun thing
about writing them you commit to the
choice that it's a dream nothing will
convince you from that moment on that it
is not a dream so you just do dream
stuff I'm Gladiator sure let's do it you
know um until you get an ax in the neck
and then you die right
but functionally compared to Heist these
are exactly the same Heist like its
endings I think the deepest ending was
about five choices in right like give or
take there's some longer maybe six or
seven it would be the the row scientist
one in the zombie path would be the
deepest one but this is like pretty
similar and it was intended that way I
wanted it to be like that because I
wanted to throw people off because I
wanted to give people the feeling
that they are stuck and I think the the
one that gives it the most is probably
uh the either the fixer from the outside
one or the mark you know you you send
Mark in a million times
um all of them have different flavors of
it but you know there there is just like
this this similar feeling across the
board of like ha I did it Adventure over
and there's so much more left to do like
beyond that
um
I'm gonna keep going forward I would
love to go back but we have a behind the
scenes video that to show you in the
Stream that I want to get to and I could
talk endlessly about this
um but yeah but the whole idea is like
and the challenge of this particular one
is how do you have a cohesive narrative
in an interactive format and the only
way to do that is to make the illusion
of choice part of the story and that is
the story of in space it is the illusion
of Choice feeling trapped I planned for
part one at the end of it when people
watched it to feel uncomfortable with
both their choices and the
inconclusivity of the story at that
point that was the point because that is
kind of the nature of it I all of the
promotional stuff that I did with the
trailers it was all asking you to
question what you did people that went
the most destructive pass first really
some of them not all of them kind of
regretted their decisions because as I
said before your first time playing this
is your Canon path that is what you
chose as Captain based on your decisions
and mentality and all the time I was
leading up to this and all the time
leading up to part two I was challenging
you to really think about the
consequences of your actions because in
this story they both matter and don't
matter that is the illusion of choice
it's how much you feel it matters that
matters so anyway go towards the way
towards the light
[Music]
software update complete good morning
Captain we are currently error years
into our journey coffee is on Route
current or ship status is
foreign
on the bridge
fire extinguished life support systems
oxygen levels Rising
Asteroid Defense System
Asteroid Defense System
colonists core temperature stabilizing
I know I know it was so fun watching
people play it yeah and then be like oh
God and so many people want a cannonball
uh so so this video obviously one of the
biggest challenges with these
interactives
um and making a Choose Your Own
Adventure in general is the fact that it
just keeps spreading out one of the
reason like structurally the difference
between Heist and this one uh why that
has so many endings why this only has
one ending is both for the story like
this story is centered around the idea
it's it's not so much that there's only
one ending it's that there is no ending
except for one there's only one way out
of an endless infinite Loop but in
Practical terms you can't make an
endless infinite Loop because it gets
exponentially bigger so there's a lot of
like Banning out and then having it
joined back together and Fanning out and
joined back together that is a practical
limitation of trying to I'm so sorry
of trying to make something that's uh
interactive and where where you can make
choices then it does make differences
it's all compromised this is not a
choice everybody this is not a choice
but uh also just like coming back to it
with the emotion for the captain the
captain in this in this show does have a
lot more emotion I'll touch on on this
later okay do you even know who you are
I've been waiting what the hell are you
doing what the hell is that what the
hell is happening
no more it ends here
you can let you do it you're gonna tell
me what you did you're gonna tell me and
then you are going to undo all of the
damage that you've done huh okay look um
lady first of all Welcome to our ship
and I know it looks bad baby alive not
you
you
everything that you destroyed
everyone that you have killed you are
going to undo everything right here
right now
first off uh so a lot of like
interesting lore stuff happening
um this is your first introduction to
Lady as far as you know uh lady how on
lady's side this is
ladies near last time meeting you
this lady has already met you many many
many many many times in fact if you'll
notice one thing that lady has is the
device lady stole this from you well not
stole uh but got this from you
in part two
that'll give you context of when in the
timeline of all these wibbly wobbly
timelines
lady is there you'll notice also the
damaged cohesive like getting those like
the stages of damage for the costume was
difficult oh also a lady played by Leo
Tipton very talented incredible job uh
but like the McGuffin right the
what were they called the temporal
displacement I never remember
they have it and if you notice not a lot
of people thought that lady was blown to
smithe runes nope lady if you'll see
this blue Flash Blue ladies Zips AB soup
is out there just in time using the
device and that's how lady got there in
the first place that's why the blue
light is there lady appeared from
Wormhole that lady created and bada bing
bada boom got out there just before your
stupid [ __ ] blew up
like this
come on
[Music]
Hey Hey sir so it is down here hey maybe
we're not all gonna die yeah
okay well it's gotta be one of these so
I'll put that one over there you get the
big one
[Music]
Paradox detected
questions
Paradox Detective
requesting
located
okay so I want to talk about a few
things here number one this is a very
story important thing but I think it's
pretty obvious this is an old version of
warp core from the previous Universe
before it all collapsed that mold Mark
put here obvious right I don't need to
talk about any more of that
um but one of the important things to
note
is that the difference between that and
this is and one of the things that like
it's it's like compromise of like
whether you give a context clue to
something or another
um you'll notice that this is similar to
the occasion when you saw lady in the
end of part two again this is spoiler if
you're just joining us live stream and
you don't want spoilers go watch the
show
um you'll notice that there's no
skeleton of lady that was a concept that
I wanted to play with here to have like
lady skeleton in the background there
um but then again that's an early
iteration not necessarily like there's
some things that I'm like ah that might
be too confusing and stuff like that and
it's like hard to do with the only few
times that we showed there's only so
many ideas that I can put in the
background and make people question what
even is no matter what the point is you
get the crystal in this moment that is
the story important thing the crystal
itself is a paradoxical because when is
it created like it's it's impossible to
locate the beginning or the end that's a
constant's theme through the show is
like everything has to end everything
has to begin the Paradox is inside the
show you don't know when they begin or
or end you can't trace it down
but the Practical thing that I want to
talk about is the the realization that I
had and this blows my mind when you were
doing VFX in a show
they hand over the vision the video that
you record to the VFX house in this case
burning tractor in Austin and they do a
great job with it and they make it
beautiful but what they don't get is
sound
so this joke of the crystal going done
so they have a shot they get the shot of
like the warp core with no Crystal no
because they put the crystal there
there's the word and then hands going
in complete silence so me writing this
joke is and and even on set I'm
explaining to people okay so this is
going to be it's gonna be like this
stupid jump scare with this Crystal
where it's like super dramatic and like
and then it goes
and then it gets you you know that
that's a joke but this went through like
five iterations and this is a tough
scene to do because of all the visual
effects and on top of it the layers of
it you know through the hands and all
the road of like getting this Crystal
place so just like practically speaking
from now on and forever and one of the
many things I'm learning is VFX must get
reference audio because so many of your
jokes are like audio first yeah right
that's how that's how I do a lot of
things is like I direct with audio I go
like this needs to go
what we learned is like eventually
because it would you'd be like I don't
understand like how to translate this is
we would just record you on your phone
doing what you just did
yeah exactly and then you just send off
like a minute long video and you'd be
like oh okay yeah we can do that it's
like it's so crazy just how little
context some people get but it's all in
the shuffle so it's like I've learned
now to communicate things in the best
way possible that's that's like a common
lesson throughout this because it's like
learning to communicate properly
good
please resolve paradox
[Music]
emergency wiki wiki protocol override
acknowledged opening cryovar
am I
for you did I did you did we
we're Immortal or something like that I
distinctly remember falling through that
door and then ending up in the center of
a star
and then slowly feeling the flesh Melt
from my bones
but I'm alive and you're alive and
remember and you remember right
this is incredible
computer activate the emergency repair
protocol the
foreign
backup system is engaged okay uh
computer can you shut down the warp core
negative cannot be reached
okay so the Wormhole sale problem and my
emergency repair protocol can shut it
down from here we need to get in the
warp course somehow but that shouldn't
be a problem for two Immortal Gods like
us the way I see it all we need to do is
keep jumping in and eventually we'll
find the right door we'll get to the
warp course shut it down save the
colonists and then you and me can enjoy
our Newfound Powers until they slowly
drive us mad and turn us away from
everything we know and love
so what do you say
come on let's jump in again what's the
worst that could happen we can die again
I guess that wasn't
that wasn't so bad
that wasn't so bad
so uh uh obviously if people haven't
seen this by now why are you here
um but
you have an option of call emergency
meeting and jump in again I'm just gonna
go ahead and jump in again I want to
jump in again yeah clearly uh to answer
a question someone asked who voiced The
Warp core that was me
um it's just like that was a lot of
dialing in you were there for the sound
sessions of like trying to get that was
hard yeah it was actually hard to do
because a lot of like the sound mixing
is like exploratory right you're kind of
creating it as you go and I know I
wanted like inspiration from the Mass
Effect Reapers but to do that I had to
go like
Paradox detected and like like multiple
different iterations of like that kind
of voice pitching it Reverb like and
like you know you would do it and we'd
get it right and then so we went back to
Texas for sound mixes I went back like
three times you went back four or five
times yeah
um back and forth here to Texas
um and so it would be like months
between you doing trying to get that
voice and so like we get it nailed down
perfectly and then a month would go by
and be like oh God like how did you get
that I know right that voice I had to
remember like what exactly it did
because to get it at first without me
there I did it in a bunch of different
ways and I didn't know how they did so
it went from Paradox detected to
paradoxes to like Paradox detected and
then just pitching it so it was
exploratory right
um this is actually one of the first
scenes we filmed I think it was the
first day this this right here this
literal shot was one of the first shots
we did uh and it was just like this kind
of set the tone for everything it was an
odd one to get on first this and the
jump ends I mean what would have been a
good one yeah we had to do it
practically because we had to do things
the bridge was ready first so we filmed
everything we could in the bridge by
myself and that's a lot of it but not a
lot of it yeah the first the first few
days of shooting all we had was like the
bridge in the hallway pretty much so
none of the cryo or reactor or any of
that was there for like the first like
week almost yeah
um yeah which dictated a lot of the
filming yeah it did well anyway let's
jump in again
hell yeah we'll be at that Wharf court
before you know it I think we were
pretty close last time too so this time
oh that's right
now
[Music]
can't believe
I'm not quite what I expected but now we
know what not to do so yeah what do you
say
let's jump in again let's jump in again
hell yeah shouldn't be long now before
resting on the shores of our new home
planet we'll be heroes for so give you a
medal and they'll give me a medal and
they'll give you a medal then they'll
give me a medal then they'll give you a
medal they might give her a medal
okay
not gonna lie
oh that was my bad I kind of got
distracted by all the pretty colors but
they do say that failure is the best
teacher so
shall we go again come on buddy friend
pal let me go
Captain Captain
jump in again
yeah no one's found this hell yeah I
think we almost had it last time it was
pretty close there I mean you kind of
screwed up but I was doing great so I'm
gonna fix what I did wrong you just do
something completely different so that
it's better and we'll get there in no
time and save all our people before they
can say
foreign
I'm not the type to assign blame but uh
I can't help but feel like you could
have tried a little harder you could
have but I want to talk about something
here because this is the first uh
uh scenes that we filmed there is this
is a this is an example of how jokes get
added in throughout the show
this and and you know people probably
weren't even paying attention to this
this is Carlos Carlos is uninjured here
and it's so it's like mind-blowing when
you really think about it because we
added in the joke that Carlos would
always be injured only after we filmed
the shot of him walking out with
crutches
yeah which was filmed after this one
because this is the first one we came up
with that joke and it wasn't like me
doing it it was all of us it was like
the art Department you know it was like
a makeup wardrobe they we had this idea
that this crew member would always be
injured because we had this thought
process like oh is this post pre-injury
oh wait he should be injured the whole
time this is one of the few times that
he is uninjured because we just didn't
think of the joke it's not like we're
gonna reshoot it yeah we're not gonna
reshoot it for that so like just from
then on he's always injured there's
multiple things in the show that are
like this where a joke only evolves as
we film it there's many jokes that were
written on the day that we filmed it
because we had the opportunity to be
flexible and you know we were able to do
these things and like these little
consistencies that we we look back and
be like oh man if only we did it but
barely anyone noticed so continuity baby
continuity baby anyway
would love to keep jumping in would love
to keep jumping in but I don't want to
spoil the secret
um people still have not found it they
have not won the grand prize I'm
actually shocked because I mean it's
pretty well hidden
um but the fact that no one's had I
think it's like a persistence thing just
no one's gone deep enough into it or
been committed enough I kind of like
laid the whole Clues with the watching
this in video 100 I bet that I don't
wanna I don't want to ruin it but you
know it's like that Olden ring like it
is it's like the door you gotta hit 50
times but you know wrote this before
that even came out so it was me first do
you need a drink I might grab a coffee
um no I got my own salad well I mean if
you give me some string cheese so I can
do that I can eat it in properly on
camera
you can eat it properly on camera
improperly oh
I'll be back okay
anyway we're gonna call an emergency
meeting
for me yeah yeah we're gonna call an
emergency
they deserve to know what's
how to solve this
this is probably not good one so
official legal approval to do this joke
I contacted
I literally got permission to do this
joke uh and ordinarily you know I
wouldn't go through the legal jumps and
Hoops but because this is a bigger
production you need to go through all
these hoops I would ask for permission
of course which I did
um but actually got legal permission to
do this one
um because you know
why not throw it in there you know do at
least one joke you can't not do it and
if you have a chance where you're doing
an emergency meeting of course you can
do the joke so we did the joke anyway
and Alexian made this little graphic
with chica there so
Captain thank you for such an upfront
and thorough explanation of the
situation the mark of a great leader
always being open and honest with the
crew never holding anything back
sweetest things turn sours by their
deeds a Lily that festers smells far
worse than weeds what
the bottom line is we need to get to the
warp core and shut it down it's having
effects that I never could have
predicted the captain and I we've tried
some things but we need fresh ideas yeah
have you tried blowing it up obviously
they've tried blowing it up look who
you're working with I know we haven't
but that is a good idea no it's not you
know nothing about wormholes you can
actually cause a false vacuum collapse
well no we wouldn't and also that's
impossible what if we back the ship up
into the wormhole
well if we pop her in reverse and just
undo
all the wormhole
stuff okay Mark I owe you an apology
because obviously you're not the
stupidest person on this ship thank you
hey Captain never do my stuff
clearly we need to send out a distress
signal because someone sabotaged this
ship you know now that she mentions it
some of the damage on the ship did seem
intentional I think someone needs to go
over every inch of this ship and do some
practice
[ __ ] because the only two people that
can change anything on the ship are me
and the captain and the only person that
I trust more than myself is the captain
two how could anybody find us if we
don't know where we are my point exactly
we don't know where we are we don't know
how we got here and we have the lives of
the colonists at stake
four
hear me out
no no it's not up to you it's not up to
you and I'm sorry it's not up to you
it's up to the captain
they haven't let us down yet that's true
it's all defer to your wisdom
okay so as many of you have guessed yes
this the damage was intentional as you
now know if you have watched part two
which if you haven't this is your last
chance I'm starting to really spoil it
go watch part two Link in the
description or part one if you haven't
seen a good Link in the description
um the damage was intentional because
old Mark did sabotage the ship I am
actually going to reveal something to
you if we go if you remember in the
opening you remember how the pilot of
the shuttle when you first come onto
this ship is like we're gonna land in
five and then you crash it's funny right
it's a joke me causing Tyler to spill
coffee and the warp core going all weird
me almost blowing up the reactor uh
ruining cryo for whatever reason that's
all old Mark even the shuttle crashing
how do you think old Mark got onto the
ship
he was on the shuttle with you
he snuck on board
but he was there with you and this all
ties in later and I'll explain more but
he caused you to crash not well not
because he wanted you to die then he
just needed to get on the ship and start
sabotaging it before you could start the
whole process because he was trying to
stop it anyway
that's why he appears three times and
the first time you see him is after the
crash
I just blew their Vines
yeah also I want to talk about oh thank
you very much I want to talk about
something this is this is an ex this
scene is a perfect example about why it
was so essential that I Had Creative
control 99 of the time YouTube was very
lovely to work with but they were able
to get notes right
Henry Henry's here yeah so this is an
example of like why it was essential to
get creative control because I had all
decisions but they were able to give
notes and sometimes they give good notes
most of the time I didn't address the
notes or I gave reasoning for the notes
but one of the things that they said and
this you in chat right now is a perfect
example of this and I swear don't get
mad at YouTube this is just a note that
they had
but their note
for this moment
was to cut this out because they said
the joke was not Landing that's what
they said and it's like it's a bad note
not only because it doesn't understand
the nature of the show you can't cut
anything out
but also it is so clear now people you
everyone who's played this [ __ ] loves
popper in Reverse I know I know I know
I know
they thought the popper in Reverse joke
was that was the literal note this joke
isn't Landing can we cut around this
it's unbelievable right I it's fine
though because I didn't have to address
it I said
literally my responsibility note was I
disagree period and that was the end of
it like
I'm pretty sure that was my exact
address to that note was this joke isn't
Landing I disagree
and that's the end of it
um but what else is so funny is this
this video was not originally named
popper in Reverse it was named back the
ship into the Wormhole because that's
what it was but when I realized how
strong of a statement literally having
the choice popper in the verse this is
actually a kind of interesting thing
into naming these choices this is an
example of a name of a choice not only
is the choice itself compelling but the
name of it is so compelling you want to
click it I'm going to make a poll right
here but I'm pretty sure I know what the
poll is going to be say hi you're too
short
you're too shrimpy bud uh
I could pick you up you can say hi
so I'm asking this send a distress
signal or popper inverse and it's like
it's just such a it's such a good choice
it's such a good it's such a fun choice
and that's the other half of this is
right I want to tell a story but I also
want to make a fun experience and this
is legitimately a fun choice that leads
to Avery oh
yeah keep talking it's a fun choice at
least to a fun Universe it is also story
wise an example of how this kind of
universe hopping
happens you hop universe is based it
gets more disconnected from your
original Universe the more times you die
right that is the basic principle of
these uh Universe jumps so popper in
reverse while funny
leads to your death and the death of the
hundred thousand columnists so we're
under your care and every crew member
who trusted you and they so trust you
that they don't even question this
oh whoops it's muted
in space we gave all the crew took a
bone and yeah all the different mugs
yeah
oh also if you want to get mugs for
yourself or uh in space merch at
cloakbrand.com link is non-description
you have to go there but cloakbrand.com
limited sales stuff there's some really
cool posters and artwork that I got
commissioned from the same person who
did the heist posters drowned man
there's like metal prints I don't know
it's still there but uh there's some
sold out but uh some are still available
so cloakbrand.com limited edition uh
space stuff really cool posters like I
love those posts also did the drown man
poster oh yeah yeah really cool stuff
anyway
no you can't possibly think about that
you heard the captain and they know
what's best I know
no sorry I feel like I'm crazy we're all
gonna die oh my God for once in your
life just step back and put your faith
in proper leadership
you got this Gavin
another day another crisis
current ship status
broken
just like my marriage
here I am again back for another ride on
the Merry-Go-Round of life
am I Immortal am I some kind of God
but was this just another cruel game
leading you on promises
in the back and leave you for dead
whatever it was yeah there's so much to
love about all this
and this is kind of like
was hard on set to get all this right
because it took a long time to set this
up set the lighting up initially we were
gonna what we wanted was to be able to
like drop the blast shield and then have
the blind trap so they built a whole
thing to do it but like it just it
wasn't gonna work yeah
but we got there and
um
this is another factor of having really
talented people that want to make
something good and allowing them time to
have a chance to do that thing this uh
uh Phil Roy Philip Roy uh was the
director of cinematography uh or
Director of Photography cinematographer
whatever he made it look pretty and uh
all the camera stuff
key worked with the lighting team and
stuff to get this specific look of
taking the time to make sure there are
slatted blinds in every Noir shot him
and I really fought over this but and
because this is right he was right but
it's hard to Envision this is the same
struggle the directors have when they
they're trying to tell people their
vision of what the their idea is you
people cannot picture what is in your
head no matter how much you explain it
they will not get the exact same picture
so you have to get a clear enough
explanation so that it it is obvious or
show them afterwards and have them just
trust you
this was worth the time to take but man
when you're fighting for every minute of
filming time it is time for me like my
job was you know working with like the
ad who would and the producers the other
producers would be in my ear being like
you need to tell Mark that this is good
enough as is otherwise it's going to
throw the whole schedule off so like
that's you were coming from like the
director's side of like I want this to
be perfect I want this and then I would
be the one who'd have to
try to make the call that something was
like good enough or like this needs to
be a concession that you have to make
right and that's always like the sort of
yeah for those of you who don't know the
dynamic of how Amy and I work together
um this is how it's been for it was for
heist for a lot of the projects that
we've made together is because I am in
front of the camera I physically cannot
be behind the camera when we're filming
I don't know what it looks like until
afterwards unless we play it back so Amy
there's no there's no way you could
watch playback of every shot it would
take twice as long it would take twice
as long to film so during the writing
process like I'm I'm involving Amy with
all this so that Amy is the only other
human in existence that knows what's in
my head better than like everywhere
everyone else second best to me in my
head is Amy and so Amy looks at every
scene knows what I want knows my style
is able to make judgment calls 99 of the
time of what is good enough and 99 of
the time I will agree we can move on
directly and I can have full confidence
that that will be what it will be there
are many occasions where I'll watch
playback because we you are like I don't
know I need you to decide if like this
is a deal breaker because you would be
catching errors a lot too errors of
things happening really like scripty
script supervisors looking at the actual
script as we watch and it's like oh we
didn't say this line and this line is
really important right making sure like
that's consistent whereas I'm looking at
it more for like visual errors right
you're acting you would trust if I came
to you and was like
do something different exactly right 100
or like a joke wouldn't land I trust
your a joke doesn't land infinitely more
than YouTube because I know your
audience exactly for how many years like
I yeah I feel like I have a decent sense
of like and I trust your sense of humor
uh it's so funny because you know uh
Amy's role in the credits is creative
producer and that is an official role is
a very important role um but you might
as well have been co-director as well uh
because uh it's it when we're on set
with Heist it was like finding that role
and people realized how essential you
were to the creative process but also
now that they saw Heist as a finished
project to this one
it was so amazing because every time
Isaac the ad would yell cut
everyone would freeze be quieter than
even when we started filming which was
always a fight for us to go like quiet
on set
shut the [ __ ] up you know but once we
yelled cut everyone froze and stopped
talking because they were waiting to
hear from Amy whether the shot was good
because we're not getting coverage on
this because it's first person so
normally you're filming a scene and
you're getting it from 10 different
angles but the the joy of first person
is when you get one take of a scene you
move on I am one uh so everyone was like
really waiting uh to hear from Amy of
whether that was good enough and and I
knew based on my performance like it
yeah if if Amy said good enough I had
full confidence that I was happy with
how I did but you can also make a call
exactly just to be like let's run it
again there were many times where he was
like that one's good and I'm like okay
it's good that's one in the can we can
get one because I think I can do better
or stuff like this there's actually one
at the end of this part one that is an
example of that
say like 90 95 of the time we agreed oh
yeah which I always thought was so funny
because like being on set is like very
it's a high it's a super high stress job
right fast-paced so like people would
I'd fight the strong word but people
would like butt heads right like that's
that's part of the job
um you try to minimize it but like it
happens right people are like fighting
for their Department like that's when it
happens
but it's funny because they're very it
was very rare that we would disagree but
there were a few times where I'd be like
this is not good enough and when we get
to post we're going to be screwed and
you're like I know it's gonna work I
know it's gonna work and everyone would
get real quiet yeah yeah like everyone
else gets to bicker
anything we have infinitely more
experience like dealing with conflict
than any of you random people do
yeah it was just very very seriously oh
God I disagree
but it's all for the betterment of the
project I would rather I would rather
anyone on set fight for what they
believed was better for the show even if
at the end of the day like I might
disagree with them and make a call and
be like no we're gonna go with this and
and I'm not I in this show even making
most of the calls like I'm I it's very
very close to what my ideal version of
it but there's some things where I'm
like I wish we'd have done something a
little differently
but to be perfectly honest it's like
this crew and this set and you being
behind camera was the only way that this
could have been made as good as it was
and that's all these projects will ever
be one of my greatest compliments that
you guys have given to me is you judge
this comparatively to movies and TV
shows with huge budgets and unlimited
resources this is a labor of love with
extremely limited resources the budget
was not small but the amount of stuff
that we squeezed out I thought it was
not small for something that wasn't
right six and a half hours seven hours
right right of course but the amount
squeezed out of it like we squeezed
every single that's a compliment like
we've heard from
people who like work more traditionally
in film and TV is when we tell them the
budget when we tell them the budget
they're like shocked not because like it
looks amazing but because of how dense
it is and how much we did like eek out
of the budget which like granted was not
that was our producers you know and
you're writing like knowing how to write
something that we could film
cheap
um yeah cheap is a comparative term it's
all very expensive
anyway you're continuing
seems like that didn't work out
let's say captain
oh well
you can't win them all
problems solved
well not all problems
not the problem with my broken heart oh
no
some problems can't be solved with a
swing of the face no matter how strong
you are when the love of your life tears
you to pieces well that's a wound that
just won't heal the kind of wounds that
lead you down
the captain looked right through me with
those baby gray eyes the kind of look
that could kill and the kind of looks
that could kill the match
maybe someday I'll work up the courage
to ask them out on that date
yeah right maybe someday I'll destroy
the universe so Captain got any other
ideas to get us out of his mouth
I'm surprised you didn't go get like
microblading afterwards between you and
Mick you guys were both like man yeah
having eyebrows like this oh man it was
so crazy because like literally the only
difference makeup wise of this character
versus any other was the eyebrows and I
didn't even think of like eyebrows is
that even gonna come across it comes
across and I would go home because I
didn't take off the eyebrows and I'd go
home and look by something really oh
damn
and Mick also like because um uh uh did
Gunther also gun throughout eyebrows and
he would look at himself in the mirror
be like oh
damn you could do this all the time
right
um I would love to go fire all weapons
at the Wormhole but you and your voice
line is in some destruction we need to
see wug yeah that's one thing that would
be it would be better we called out many
things to show in this one yeah
and everyone's seen firewall weapons
Ethan does The Voice
it's a very fun one but it's also the
the whole Crux of this destructive path
and getting a ways you need to know some
context but the more careless you are
the less story you understand right
that's the principle if you make unwise
decisions as a captain and let's be
honest they are unwise decisions you
don't know the full breadth of the story
because of course you don't like why do
you deserve it you don't that's kind of
dorian's thing is like like having fun
Captain that's it's very meta there
anyway sending a distressing
so shush
shame on you
sounds good Captain you always know the
right move to make
it's a terrible idea the worst that I've
heard yet sure the captain was pretty
but they were clearly an idiot oh face
and no brains and no ways out here we
were doomed cursed down Thumbs Up dunion
Ring
signals out Captain all that's left to
do now is wait until
something's coming boss it's terrible
it's horrible get yourself together and
tell us what it is detecting an energy
buildup from an unknown battle it's some
kind of alien spaceship
[Music]
hey there's no need to be so hostile
far beer for one to judge a new species
on looks alone but flying through a
wormhole
you're either Reckless it's more stupid
foreign
[Music]
not the first time buddy and I'm sure
that it won't be the last
sure I was scared I was downright
terrified the urine soaking into my
pants made me regret not building a
recycling system into the suits but I
kept my cool because when the chips are
down
you play the hand you dealt I'm sure
that there's
some way that we could resolve this
hammock I love the piss job
some way it's this scene especially is a
culmination of so many different
editions and little like nuanced things
while the conditions for filming it were
hell not Wade is a trooper the wug is
played by Wade and Wade had to deal with
this costume being what it is which is
like
15 layers of different pieces of armor
assembled together and two helmets he
has a mask on underneath there that's
what the eyes are and then the helmet
over that he can't see anything he is he
was literally blind the entire time he
played wug he could not see period so
everything else is just him guessing
where he's looking and everything and
meanwhile he's sweating his ass off his
giant ass off I'll talk more about it
but we'll do it uh after we finish
through the scene could resolve this
amicably the
Republic's disgust for what must be the
ugliest member of their species and yet
the leader well I could never laid eyes
on a creature so handsome and or
beautiful those eyes they're captivated
walk glamoring like the great forests to
blog maybe there was hope for this
species yet
strong
at least they didn't seem like a violent
species what doubted that they knew
about the ancient peace treaty an attack
on one block was an attack on all one as
the same goes and yet part of what
wanted them to attack one something it
works blood yearned for the final
satisfaction of savage destruction just
like walk's ancestors walk like helping
but we're also like hurting
[Music]
please
disappointed that worked out right
downstairs
maybe something went wrong with one's
translator very beautiful you ever think
was ugly stupid stupid I'm just glad
work but their recycling systems
thank you
these people help
take this here
you want to
you don't have to
understand
[Music]
always helped you
thanks wug we appreciate it
I hope our paths cross okay
okay so I'm pausing there because I'm
going to show you something that is
going to blow your minds maybe maybe not
the the blowing of one's mind will be uh
determine on how fragile your mind is to
being blown but that scene that scene
with wug in Noir Universe went from
being the scene I was most concerned
about and was the least happy with to
one of my favorite scenes and long and
it was slow long and slow and no action
it's just dialogue yeah like and uh the
original way that that was filmed and
the original dialogue that I had it is
only through the benefit of wug
literally not having a face that that
scene worked out the way it did
um what I'm about to show you is a pre
uh just purely assembly version so
there's gonna be like a lot of numbers
and stuff on the screen don't worry
about that it's just notation for for
the filmmaking process
um but this will be the basically
original version of the scene and this
is how things can change in making these
well you're about to see may shock you
see
alien spaceship
hey there's no need to be so hostile
dumb people
big danger
so dumb
but what help
what always helps
not the first time buddy and I'm sure
that it won't be the last sure I was
scared I'll still be terrified
[Music]
because when the chips are down
I'm sure that there's
some way that we could resolve this
amicably
coward
coward very ugly not like handsome and
or beautiful leader
very brave
beautiful gray eyes
worth helping
we go
okay
one just bloody no Attack One
if attack one they break free
I'll walk in war if break peace
more very fun
but not peace
was like help but what also like hurt
maybe what what they attack one
foreign
[Music]
oh okay anyway all right so what the
what this amounts to is
when I wrote it it was not intentionally
that it wasn't supposed to be that slow
at first but the nature of the filming
of the scene it got slower as time goes
on because we kind of like really leaned
into this like super smooth styling
um
but what did amount do is like the
filming day that we had was so dense
once we realized there was a problem
there was no time to fix it as we were
filming
so we just had what we had and that is
what we had it is slow and I wrote the
narration for wug as if he was speaking
out loud whereas I changed it to the
point where wug had full sentences and
spoke
in his narration and then spoke out loud
as wogg normally does
much better change way better seen all
the better I was just gonna say I saw
people asking about Rooster Teeth
um they were like one of the production
companies the production company so they
did the assembly and a lot of the crew
came from there yeah I'm actually
surprised that people don't know it it's
like in the credits of course right but
Rooster Teeth was the production company
for this Rooster Teeth was also the
production company for heist so it was
rooster teeth's art Department Rooster
Teeth wardrobe Department
um and a lot of props came from on the
rooster teeth so the producers or
rooster teams producers and whatnot uh
yeah so if you've seen and what what's
their their space show their the two
space movies oh yeah laser teams laser
teams if you've seen Laser team you'll
recognize some of the props things like
that
um because it's the same art Department
yeah also this VOD will be posted
afterwards so don't worry about that
um the other thing I want to say is just
like a big thank you to Rooster Teeth
for being the production company on this
they were great help in like having them
do Heist and then this also will help
but a big screw you know
they they it was funny because we talked
about when we filmed Heist that they had
the Laser team sets and a lot more stuff
and I told them I think I want my next
one to be in space can you save those
sets because I there's definitely stuff
that would be of value to use and then
they just threw them away they just
threw them away and I was like you knew
I was gonna do I think because everyone
thought when you were teasing the space
idea when we wrapped Heist everyone
thought you were joking everyone thought
I was joking that's why Wade tweeted out
publicly you said you were gonna go
space you promised and I had to text him
friendly do it oh my God [ __ ] ice has
been out for a day and you spoil it so
anyway but it's fine it all worked out
but this was this was a tough scene that
that did turn out way better because of
the changes that we made and like the
ever-evolving
creative process now back to this scene
I hope our paths crossed okay
[Music]
like just here he is new species huh
they won't last a day that's Amy's voice
today they won't last yeah I'm getting
mad at like 10 p.m they're in a sound
mix yeah I know right we're way lately
thank you for visiting
[Music]
a
visit
I didn't have nothing to do with that
Wormhole everyone just fell asleep
Morgan Morgan
I want a lawyer I have rights another
something you don't see every day ah
it's like fresh gray grass yeah like the
first gray rays of sunshine and a hand
glowing with the gray light of an
unstable warp Crystal oh yeah my gut was
telling me that they were something
special
more special than that ugly one that one
makes my gut turn just looking at them
and my guts never steered me wrong
before
when will Mark write a female character
that doesn't hate him not hate just
finds to be horrendously ugly I'm just
saying like lady Chelsea Bandit
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you didn't know well okay there's
multiple wugs some wug lore right I'll
get to it when we get there that's about
to happen it's about to happen but the
all wugs
well it's not that they look the same
that's insulting to wug to our human eye
to our human eye they all look the same
but it's so clear if you're a wug
they're all different the wug that is
about to show up is a female wug the
other wug on the ship is you well I mean
does it matter why are you asking
anyway
um um I don't know oh Morgan right no
our voice is so good and like we spent
forever she was a local cast out of
Texas and we spent so long trying to
decide on who was going to play Bandit
because we were down to a few people and
we're like oh so good and we ended up
deciding on Morgan but Morgan had never
done the Noir voice yeah she just
auditioned like
for the normal Bandit yeah and then she
just pulls this out and it was just like
what that's the problem with like
casting and and to see it from the other
side a lot of actors like you know they
they auditioned so many times and you
know it's so rare but that's the problem
of it we got like 30
auditions just for Bandit and and almost
all of them were so good would have been
fantastic how do you make that choice
what like I'm so glad like that Morgan
was there I'm not saying that Morgan was
replaceable because obviously Morgan did
an incredible job as Bandit also did not
expect all the fan art like that was new
uh this is very sweet very sweet very
very helpful incredible like did a great
job anyway
wonderful but also how do you make those
choices also same with Doreen and Linda
playing Dory oh man uh wonderful
a little bit of a weird weird day hey
Captain
well well well
if it isn't
the humans
so lost
so I remember uh just pause it real
quick because I remember talking with
the Wardrobe people about this I'm like
maybe we could do something in reference
to like lady that was kind of like in
that vein they just literally copied the
costume that's great I thought we were
gonna get in trouble like that's what I
originally thought anyway
well that's a lot of talk for someone
outnumbered two to one who am I
I'd like to introduce you to my
associate
wug
so this is the female one how could you
do this to us after all we've been
through we've never met
you sure you look just like this guy
what you think I want what's the same
my [ __ ]
if you're done insulting my associate
I'm gonna have to ask you to drop your
weapons and come with me
with me not gonna happen yeah we haven't
come all this way to give up now don't
be stupid
that's why you have to drop your weapon
so we
we're the only ones who can
so you better surrender
yeah so uh I'll give a poll for this one
um
oh but the
yeah this wug is not the same wug
as the wug that just escorted you on the
ship
it's not this is a different wug that's
why the joke some people didn't get this
but it's just like I go like how could
you do this to me we never met and
people don't take that at face value
anyway so um yeah I will follow this
poll
because you know it's water every time
you would think the two things that you
cared about in sound mixes was more
anytime you'd gesture with your hands
you'd want more whooshes yeah yeah and
anytime there were guns you wanted more
gun Rattle and it was so funny because
when I went into the sound session Brad
is the guy who did the sound mixing
incredible job he is a consummate
professional also just fun to work with
understand sound to a T is incredibly
talented uh but also what was so funny
is because I he he did Heist as well so
we have worked together he knows kind of
like what I like we come into the scene
he plays this for me there's so many gun
rattles here and he looks over at me
with a big old smile on his face like
what do you think and I go like really
good can we get a few more gun rattles
in there and I swear he thought I was
joking he thought I was joking because
he put so many in there there's no way
it's like the Bubba Wubba scene it's
exactly I love this dynamic
it's just so funny and phys I love
physicality in my things and it was just
like he has to like he he literally was
just like oh my God
but I love working with he's very
talented he's so fun to watch work oh
yeah so like it's like watching a a
master pianist like just play
you played piano
just like just magic Woody was able to
work and like I would give him a
description like it needs to go no
[Music]
anyway you guys won't give the signal
which I I do love give the signal
uh that is the theme from Heist
it's I Don't Want to Be Free
not many people caught that good whistle
I did that one you did
[Music]
you okay captain
it is a surrender you're surrendering
Captain would never surrender
that's the mark having the tiniest gun
yes
no way no it's it's not a signal is it a
signal Captain it's not a signal no way
it definitely Circle
okay what
um talking about this location I think
we had a note to talk about the
universal stability right right oh my
God we did I've I think so before we get
to that where you see this shot where
one guns you down
we had so many debates about whether or
not to include this in a trailer right
you didn't until like one of the
glitches the glitch versions of the
trailer yeah and my argument
um was not to include it not because it
was spoilery or anything but I was like
do you want 95 of the comments on the
trailer video to be Lady D yeah exactly
round out any other actual comment about
this project I know yeah it's it's just
like anything on uh Doug's videos and
streams where people you guys latch on
to the tiniest things like popper in
reverse the freaking
don't play you latch on to the tiniest
things and you were totally right it
would have been every comment because
literally when this scene came out all
people said was where do they literally
right here people just go
so this was not in the original trailer
for the simple fact that you guys cannot
control yourself
anyway uh but also just like talking
about this location this is another
thing about filmmaking is when I
originally wrote this right I wanted
this to be a Gover an alien government
agency that's what it is the universal
stability agency I imagined in my head a
very hyper modern kind of like respect
we should have filmed it where the intro
the bank vault in Heist is with those
round windows yeah that would have been
beautiful literally you could already
use it yeah the same I mean I didn't
even think about it at the time and I
don't think we could have gotten it but
literally the same location that we
filmed the bank the Museum of heist
would have been great for it but that's
what I imagine like really hyper modern
kind of White Walls cool windows it's in
space
couldn't do that we had this kind of
location for a clean room of a
fabrication but they had too many rules
of filming of filming there this is
actually an archival Library this scene
right here is the same scene that we
filmed everything of where in the world
is Markiplier with Tyler and Ethan Tyler
freaking hair I can't wait to talk about
that
um but it's all about compromise right
so we only had this location and it
looks like a shitty government building
because it is a shitty government
because it is a shitty Texas government
building it's it's kind of run down it's
kind of old smells old so I was like all
right we'll just Embrace that it's a
shitty government building but it worked
great because like I don't know exactly
but Texas has
um like basically you can film for free
at a lot of like text because like they
want to encourage filming there yeah um
which is why we were able to film at
that library for heist um for nothing I
think I think it was free and here I
think we did have to pay but but it's
like you can film pretty cheap in these
like government buildings and they're
like well that'll be the bit then is you
have this glorious exterior shot of like
this crazy ship and then it's like this
janky ass old building yeah and and
that's like how it goes and so we
embraced that someone said it looks like
a DMV yes that was the idea so we're
like okay even aliens have shitty
government buildings that's how it's
going to be and that's what we did and
it works really well for the Noir look
it looks incredible for the Noir look
and the normal one it looks like a
shitty office
um anyway carrying on
actually I'ma hit the bathroom if you
can take over
with the sucking whoosh and a swirl of
blue energy the captain of the
Invincible two finds themselves back in
their cryopod
Captain looks around slightly confused
for unknown reasons eventually they get
on with it and pull the emergency
release to free them from the confines
of their cryogenic prison
stepping out of the Pod the captain
wonders to themselves if they are
perhaps stuck in some sort of purgatory
doomed to endlessly repeat the mistakes
of the past
the captain's Intrepid engineer also
wonders the same as they emerge from
their pod
Captain do you hear something the
captain laughs a boisterous laugh at
what is obviously another one of Mark's
hilarious rules I love hilarious Mark
must still be Delirious from the after
effects of cryogenic Slumber right now
to be honest we've all seen this part
before and I don't want the viewers at
home to get bored so why don't we skip
ahead a few pages and yeah it is a good
friend Aaron Hansen technically playing
doctor Festival
wag being the stoic battle-hardened
brute that he is is unfazed by this new
turn of events and proceeds to extract
the English language out of Mark's soft
supple skull what
balance the ship to the space fast food
restaurant
okay
um the space fast food restaurant was an
idea we had at the beginning and I wish
we could have had a longer
scene with it when we first uh
brainstormed the show
talking about the fast food restaurant
are you okay
yeah that this was like kind of a bit
that we wanted to do from the very
beginning like the holy alien team from
the very beginning of the brainstorming
session this is one of your ideas we was
like no sap in the car like gosh to have
an alien drive through and like that was
critical to it so yeah and it's
fascinating because this looks so good
like it's just a testament to the talent
of the uh you know the VFX artists like
they they really did a great job in
setting this up because it's just
Danielle standing on green yeah did you
talk about Daniel is actually uh one of
the Wardrobe right wardrobe oh she's
wardrobe but she does act as well so
sometimes she's in a few different
places in the show like part two uh
things like that this video oh it is in
this video
um yeah because we were just like
quickly need an extra and she was like
let me do it yep
the captain grabs the food
it's such a good costume
that's supposed to be a wug only fast
food restaurant
the ship arrives at the universal
stability I don't think it's in the BTS
video because I don't know if I ever
uploaded it but we do have a video of
Mark I have a video on my phone of Mark
eating the taco because it is fully
edible the one the one taka or whatever
oh yeah no that thing was weird would
have been sitting out all day too it's
like mushrooms and and noodles and
noodles and more mushrooms yeah and a
lot of food coloring anyway the agency
owie
and so our Intrepid adventurers have
arrived at the universal stability
agency but is it too late for them to
stop the rampaging Wormhole that they
have Unleashed upon the cosmos the
captain thinks back to all the faces of
the colonists under their care
will they be able to save them or will
they be doomed forever to suffer the
same fate over and over again and will
Mark ever learn the captain's deep dark
secret
but only one way to find out
the Bandit
Morgan please
what have you done not so fast now we
get to the interrogation
you are destroying everything the Bandit
knocks out late
what
um I said the Bandit knocks out lady
that's not my name and no I'm not gonna
do that
so hard not working with professionals a
vent cover falls on lady's head
yeah uh I I also wanted to say like I
thought it was so interesting and I knew
this was I kind of knew this was going
to happen it's like how
people's feelings towards certain
characters evolved over time old Mark
kind of saw it the most but also ladies
saw it with like part two you see the
full complement of them it's like
judging a book by its cover how dare you
but there is something funny about like
well people apply her
no because people get so frustrated
because they were expecting there to be
multiple endings in part one and then
you just keep getting yeah
anyway what the hell and back to the
ship there we are back on track and not
a moment too soon
with a device from the Bandit and hand
our Intrepid captain now has the tools
necessary to make their way to the warp
core without further delay but will the
twisting holes of the inventory what did
you say they have the uh
ah the portable temporal displacement
device you know the MacGuffin that
allows our captain to navigate the chaos
that is this ship I didn't give them
anything like that oh my God
the captain looks down and sees the
device
it glows
the captain can get to the warp core now
they just have to find it there all you
need to do now is use the device and
you'll be well on your way to part two
of this whole ordeal so the real
business can begin I'm sorry
oh yeah
what does that mean you're not supposed
to be here
I am so confused
I don't know what the hell's going on
but if there's another option that gets
us out of here that doesn't involve
listening to a crazy voice in our head
we might want to take that one
there is no other option written here
next page literally says the captain
uses the device and in a flash of
blinding light is transported to another
Universe there's no other way
must move forward
alright so uh one thing I want to talk
about um because obviously we're not
going to get to it in another path we
just don't have enough time is uh this
whole
what the concept that I was talking
about oh it's not even on the projector
here right
the whole concept of like the more
chaotic your choices are or literally
the more destructive it is all of you
chanting plan okay plan okay is the less
you know lady doesn't even have a chance
to make an accusation other than what
have you done you are destroying
everything
there is less and less context for the
situation that you are in because you
are too busy shouting for plan K and I
am not going to give you plan K because
as you can plainly see uh there is no
other option oh would you look at that
there's nothing else see how would we
even be able to tell you about how this
show and it's intricate store how do you
even know the lore if you don't even
give me the chance to show you the lore
we have a whole behind the scenes video
that we're going to show you it's I
think how long is it it's like a half
hour I don't know maybe I didn't look at
the time but a whole behind the scenes
the scenes video prepared for the stream
that we are going to show you live and
you don't even want to do it because you
want to blow up the ship didn't you
learn you blow up the ship a hundred
thousand people die
why do you think blowing up the ship is
good I want to hear your justification
why do you think blowing up this ship is
a good idea because if you have not
guessed the whole idea is this is not a
time reset you are jumping to another
universe but the universe that you just
jumped from suffered all the
consequences
the universe you just jumped from
suffered all the consequences of your
actions
it's not how it works they didn't reset
they are dead
and they will stay dead
oh
my
God
anyway
here's advice good idea good idea
excellent perfect
Joyce
trust me this is the best possible
outcome although it might not seem like
it at first
actually wait hold on
oh
oh no what
um
no spoilers but maybe don't trust any
talking doors what the hell does that
mean
we made it
you guys were flying around in this
thing oh well she's seen better days
said
and
yes this is Ed from heist with
markiplier you thought sodapoppin wasn't
in this one boom there he is you see him
right there
and baby
I think did Adam just bring that that
wasn't in the script right I think our
prop guy just had that yeah I think he's
just had that
which is so good it's dead it's Ed from
Heist yep crazy
all the what was the roast beef
was it was it roasted no uh I don't
remember was it roast beef
oh there's something else
I don't know anyone remember I can't
even remember anyway pot roast I don't
know
oh prime rib of course
oh a rib eye filet mignon
where's the crew
[Music]
all right that's just how your people
build computers right
well that's not
not how it's been in the past
um
who do they need help
well they probably don't
not need help
the captain can check on him come on
yeah
well you're the captain you're in charge
of the crude morale speeches
whose hands are that I don't remember
oh
my God
that's not me Captain
that's not me
well that's not me
good morning Captain I just leave good
you feeling good
so this shot was very difficult and what
happened here is this is a shot that
should not have had a dummy replacement
but because you don't see it but there's
no other there was really like it and
this is like we should have put the
camera on
uh sort of a tripod to keep it stable it
was like this was a lesson that we
learned to do that from then on because
this is an incredibly took so many
iterations to get it I can't believe I
saved it yeah you'll see just like this
little warping right up here that's the
only indication because there's flashing
light that covers it but this is like
clearly you're doing tricks if that's
not me and then this little blending is
all you see in there
um they did they worked a miracle to
make this work shots look nothing like
Morgan is in a different spot entirely
that that's how different it is and
that's because we we weren't paying
close enough attention to it we were
trying to do too many tricks at the same
time but it was saved and but let me
tell you we learned the lesson from that
and never did it that way again
anyway human ships are please tell me
this is just how human ships are well
they're not
not like this sometimes
[Music]
oh
uh one of your crew members are the
important one oh yeah I forgot my keys
in the bridge
uh well before we do that can you tell
us which crew member you are
specifically
mmm you know it's not really important
who I am what's really important is that
you need to open this door and quick
side it's very young dark just think of
this with the dark path
use the device and get us the hell out
of here why are we getting around like
morons just get the hell out of here hey
we still have to save the ship you
didn't tell me how messed up your ship
is don't insult her she's got character
yeah I've got characters
stopping up the store and see how much
I've got
do not open that door
do not let anyone tell you how to do
your job
you're the boss
but maybe don't do that
so this is this is an example why
um I I know you guys
I know you guys well so many of you ran
screaming arms open into this door
because I knew you would no that's not
darkiplier on there I literally released
a video series on my channel literally
called don't open the door and you guys
don't learn your lesson
it's so tempting but this is also kind
of thing is like as much as I want to
like ooh you make bad choices you people
die I literally made these choices for
you because I knew they would be fun too
right so it's like a whole thing of like
it's fun but also like
I'm gonna use the your Temptations to
kind of like drive you in one way or
another and technically you do get to
the warp core if you open the door but
also the lesson was not learned in part
two literally part two had a open the
door don't open the door and there is an
actual prize on The don't open the door
side that not many of you have found
you haven't visited him in a while you
know
also yeah no this is tight this tight
but this is not only not darkiplier on
the other side of this I meant to talk
about this earlier but one thing that
lore implication wise that I wanted to
run by this uh or I wanted to say and I
will explain further about it
this is not actor Mark
controversial I know what is it
apparently there were so many people
that like were automatically like haha
ever they based everything in their
thought process on the idea that this
would be actor Mark this is not
and I will explain this further down the
road some of you have reached this
conclusion already with the like
assumption I don't know where the
Assumption came from either it was very
quickly in Assumption it was an
assumption that carried on and then
everyone heard the Assumption from other
people assuming and then yeah see what
what exactly right yeah it was it was an
assumption that it would be and it was
those assumptions about this story and
what it would be and what it should be
that kind of like threw people for a
loop playing it they had expectations
going into it and like I'm trying to
like wrap their header up preconceived
notions going into the story made them
confused when the story went in
different directions and I've leaned
into that I knew that would happen it's
why I leaned into the fake endings in
the middle part of this that's why I
leaned into the open-ended nature of
this it's why there's these taunting
choices about the dark path or even the
musical in the next choice after this
you know it's all these things this is
not actor Mark
it's
[Laughter]
I will explain this more later I will
explain this later
um because it will all make sense also
you can think whatever you want like are
you yeah oh yeah you have your that's
also you have your intention yeah yeah I
I have my and this is what I say in
every explanation for years like I have
my intention but one of my points my
talking points that I've wrote down the
bottom here that I'm going to get to in
more detail that explains this I
literally wrote These down
um there's different levels of infinite
there's the infinite possibilities of
what I could come up with you know my
other universes and there's an infinite
number of interpretations of that for
every single one of you infinite upon
infinite upon infinite that's one of the
major themes of this story is about
infinite possibilities the Multiverse
not only is the universe infinite the
Multiverse is infinite it's infinite
infinites there are different levels of
it but anyway
this ain't him this ain't him guys does
he even remotely behave like him
that's what you gotta ask yourself
anyway ah
[Music]
screw their wants and needs don't open
this door
probably the life is for the living but
I think that might have been a trap
agreed the sooner we go the sooner I get
off this show
pretty much
democracy failed us
it's really an electoral college in this
voting system so really if you think
about it
good to see you again cap you know I've
been thinking
we need a little change of management
around here see after you were abducted
I got to thinking who got us in this
mess in the first place
and I think it all comes down to bad
leadership
now I tried to play your way really
I tried to get to the warp core best I
could I jumped into a wormhole full sin
There's No Escape in this not with you
in charge I can see that clearly now
so why don't you step down as Captain
and let somebody with the guts to do
what it takes run this ship from here on
out
well what do you see cap
you're willing to do the right thing
so what Gunther's talking about not only
am I wanting to see this for the sake of
like a lot of the really good acting
that Mick does here tragically he got
this perfectly almost perfectly on the
second take but he messed up the last
line he was so mad and it was right
before lunch and then we went to lunch
after so we got to Stew eating his lunch
like I [ __ ] up but he did such an
incredible job I can't do it but also
people focus too much when it comes down
to lore analyzes
on the obvious right the Doreen
literally like giving you clues about
things in the past and not the things
that the people in there because the
problem with thinking of that Mark as an
actor means that you think of all of
this as just an act as just like nothing
it has no meaning it does it's a story
I'm telling a story but this story is
not a story in a story this story is
about people about people and their
choices and the fact that you as Captain
are not the only one making choices in
it other people have choices to make and
they have motivations and they have
wants and drives
um like if you look at it as if it's all
just a play For Your Entertainment you
lose connection with the actual
consequences of what you're doing you
lose connection with the lives that are
lost and the people that are relying on
you and you as Captain and your
responsibility to those people now in
the end yes it's it's just fun but a lot
of what Gunther is saying here
is motivated
you did blow up the ship you wanted to
the only reason it's not blown up right
now is because I stopped you from
blowing it up that is true and that is a
fact for this Gunther
he is entirely Justified to Mutiny
against you
and he'd be right he'd be absolutely
right with this audience right here he
with this you guys as Captain the
collective you as a captain right now he
would be absolutely right
anyway uh
are you gonna let them voter you I'm
gonna guide it because we gotta get
going we're gonna be here forever gone
through think of the holidays
I also want to see bird because Bert's
computer line is so [ __ ] good I am
thinking of the colonist captain
but the question I got to ask myself
it's for you
were you thinking of them when you were
out there having fun were you thinking
of them when you abandoned us were you
thinking of them when you destroyed our
ship
are you thinking of them right now
what's that some special captains thing
foreign
in an attempt to find a deeper
understanding of this quandary in which
we find ourselves and low
against the web of the infant hopeless
Souls weren't dull against the waves of
Eternity all will be consumed by
Darkness
but in darkness lie salvation
I have modified the reactor to create a
singularity that will collapse unto
itself and take the Wormhole with it
though our ship will be destroyed so too
will our suffering
do not try to change my mind or I have
touched the fabric of reality I have
dropped deep the knowledge of infinity
you are but a monk of dust against the
mountains and is my mind
I love this dinosaur I mean you were
getting into old man when we filmed this
yeah
you didn't see it until it was like
compiled yeah obviously I love this
scene so much just because I love Bert
as a character like this is super
eloquent side of bird is like what I
really like this like reminds me of the
tweet that I saw recently that was like
oh I loved the show
um I'm really proud of like Mark and the
crew and his writers and yeah and his
writers and I'm like
hey
right or I can't tell this is all coming
from one man's mind
anyway I want to also address something
that people were saying there's a lot of
people who are like but actors in this
show he's there you see behind the
scenes and I go yeah so's Noir Mark so
bomb disposal mark
shows Yancy
uh so's campaign
they're all there
doesn't mean it's really camp counselor
all along you know what I mean that
would have been funny you're just
continuously I know yeah oh my God I'll
save that for another joke down the road
um but but the reason I say that is
because there's another compliment side
of this with the infinite concept
um you as the captain and the you the
captain that is in this is you but you
can be you know misinterpreted you may
be listening to this and think I'm
speaking to you personally that is
watching this video which I am but I'm
speaking to all of you that you is still
you but it's all of you at once the
captain in this show
is all of you at the same time each of
you makes different choices each of you
would do different things the polls here
show it you are not it's not 100 in one
decision you would all do different
things there are infinite versions of
you you are the Multiverse of you
tangibly playing this at the same time
but the whole Crux of the story is that
you and all these Multiverse versions of
you are overlapping
the U is making different choices at the
same time
you are
the captain's version of actor you I'm
talking to a different you are the
captain's version of Yancy you are
fragments of yourself from different
universes you watching this is one but
you I'm talking to is all you are the
darkiplier of the captain you are the
wharf stash of the cabin one of you is
that many of you may be that you are not
all one thing you this has been a
concept through all of the of the the
stuff since since who killed Markiplier
is the the viewer as a character is
literally all of you at once and nothing
is more clear about that concept than
this show with its multiversal thing the
reason Gunther can say those things and
you disagree with them but him still be
right is because there's another version
of you literally a different viewer that
has made those decisions
and they are all true because it all
overlaps
that's the Crux of you being the captain
anyway
which one
blow it up before it blows you up
because I want to see Morgan's scene
there
what that's making cannot Avail you but
also don't do it
Oh Captain there you are the wolf Court
finally
what did you do this
oh my gosh
do anything it's just a wormhole problem
we just need to solve it it's horrible
no it's not
normal you did something what did you do
look having a little help here
you
you just decided
it was a perfectly reasonable position
I'm gonna pause there because many
people may listen and not understand
what she meant by you blew us up
the Bandit was there when you initiated
plan K the problem of being stuck on
this ship is use it's it is a black hole
like it's a wormhole that's like a black
hole once you go onto the ship you are
stuck because the ship is stuck in a
wormhole until you resolve the Paradox
so anyone anyone that steps foot on this
ship is doomed you're stuck in part one
of the show for a month essentially
exactly you're stuck looping not dying
jumping between different Universe
versions of yourself memories from other
parts of the uni these this Multiverse
bleeding over to you you dying not
remembering how maybe you do remember
how and still living it's all mixed up
in these things where you jump between
different versions of yourself this
Bandit is a different version of Bandit
than the Bandit that blew up with plan K
just because there are two choices
doesn't mean that they are the same
Bandit that choice splits multiverses
choices split the Bandit that you use
the device with is different than the
Bandit that blows up with plan K but is
also all the same Bandit that is right
here contemplating these deaths that the
Bandit has felt
so the Bandit is correct that you blew
up the ship as if it was a completely
reasonable decision and yet the Bandit
is still there right in front of you and
can't contemplate the conflict and the
dissonance of that impossibility it's a
paradox
uh not right now but do you remember
dying maybe oh look I remember dying and
that's not remember that
hey oh is it really dying it doesn't
count
I remember
every time the captain remembers we've
been shot stabbed blown up beaten eaten
like I remember the first time when we
jumped Through the Wormhole
come
it's just
a dream do any of our choices matter
before
I'm gonna put up a poll for this because
this like the reason I went to this
scene
is because it is important if you if
this is a lore stream this is probably
the most everyone's so focused on Doreen
this is the most important besides maybe
the ending as far as like the the Crux
of the theme of this show and what you
really care about yeah exactly this is
the most important scene in part one if
if that's if you're trying to understand
what I care about the Doreen one
that's just that's fun that's
reprimanding you for making dumb but fun
decisions old Mark doesn't answer any
questions raises more questions than it
is this asks the real question
do you think you as a viewer you have to
make a determination have you been here
before that question was asked all the
way back in the trailer has this
happened before is this the first time
you've done all of this and if you don't
remember how would you even know the
answer
if you can't trust your own memories of
what's real and not real like it's up to
you do your choices matter
does anything matter these are the
questions and conclusions that I wanted
people to come to and some people come
to them and they're like like I love
seeing it because they're like that's
just like it's an illusion of choice
this is all [ __ ] therefore it's all
nonsense well so is Heist but you know
it was still fun yeah but I really
wanted people to ask themselves
what happened to the first invincible
where is in space with markiplier part
zero
which is existing it does exist
it says does it yeah in my head
anyway
and also similarly whether you've been
here before or you've never been here
doesn't matter
because the important choice
the one that can actually save you and
all your people
is yet to come
so these both lead to the exact same
thing
yeah yeah of course
makes sense
that makes perfect sense hey Captain
Hook it's the warp cord we made it I
knew we could do it it took long enough
though
unless this is one of those doors that's
trying to kill us
in which case you should probably go
first so uh
I'll get the door for you
someone just asked if that was a bad
decision there are no bad decisions
really that's what Doreen says at the
end of part two you know
because the whole point is a little like
yeah you think about it as a story you
know you have these people on your mind
but it's an illusion of choice you know
up until a point anyway part zero has
been viewed 11 million times I'll give
you that clue
wow I finally made it that took long
enough come on Captain it's time to
finally end this that is if that thing
actually works because I still have a
lot left to learn about wormholes
you do know how to use that thing don't
you Unfortunately they do
oh
not again
this is
my last chance this is the last chance
to save the universe so I am begging you
give me the crystal
hey that's a nice bracelet you got there
sure would be a shame if the computer
activated the defense turrets
sure would be a shame if the computer
inverted gravity
terrible if they could have ended all
the oxygen
that'd be bad it'd be so bad
yeah we want the same thing
is why it's important we test out the
Event Horizon
didn't feel a thing
oh okay
self-destruct
wow no defensive measures
no denting wow
nothing there will be nothing because I
have
fixed every system on this ship and I've
overridden every insane and violent
contingency that you could possibly ever
have
why are there why are there so many
self-destructs and just like one repair
protocol
you wouldn't get it
right because of your carelessness and
how many universes have you destroyed
so mad we're just going to reset things
and fix it it's fine
that's that's not how it works you
Reckless careless idiotic monsters
these aren't Second Chances every
mistake has cost the lives of people who
have trusted you
the Multiverse is littered with the
corpses of your failures
so unless unless we can undo whatever it
is you're about to do
then every living thing in existence
will be snuffed up forever
we're not we're not trying to hurt
anybody we're just trying to save our
people
the captain wouldn't do that
Captain you wouldn't let that happen
would you
done being nice
give me the crystal
yeah
stop no no no no no no no no no no okay
so a few things here number one Leo did
an amazing job also I think Leo's back
was like was that during this yeah that
was afterwards so like yeah
I had serious back injuries I was fine
in the beginning before we started
filming it was bad during pre-production
I got better because like they give me
all those shout out to Leo for going to
like a chiropractor or a hospital or
whatever in rural Texas and
so like they're waiting for like the um
it's one of the PAs to like drive them
and stuff and the costume girls coming
and they're like oh like do you want us
to take off your wig and stuff like you
know because like yeah yeah yeah you're
wearing this whole costume like before
you leave streamer comfortable and
Leia's like I mean if I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go in the full costume yeah so
like mid mid filming I think it was like
the harness stuff like for the the
falling Through the Wormhole stuff that
that hurt Leo's back Leo had to go get
that checked at a chiropractor we had to
like stop filming for the day totally
understandable this happened that's why
we got the war stash scene that's how we
got the war session we had time for that
uh to add that in that was not
originally in the script on the hallway
uh but it was just like so here's like
afterwards all this bit I just remember
like Mick oh I have a video of it
because like we would hang out after
like some nights when people are in town
yeah um so it was like the it was like
Leo's back was hurting like that day but
they were like it's okay
um so the night we were hanging out and
it was like everyone like
giving them like the most intense back
like massage
were just like
the next day they came in they're like I
can't I'm dying
that's like I remember seeing from
before I'm like that doesn't look like
it's helping because I had done the foam
roller on my back and that's that made
it so much worse I was like well these
things like come on anyway
um incredible stuff anyway story wise
this is
like I do revive
literally Mick full elbow like you gotta
really work out the knots
it's not that kind of a look at her
bones crunching
anyway
uh so this is the first address of the
concept where Mark here engineer Mark
does not know the full ramifications of
it the first seed of Doubt planted in
Engineers Mark's head against you the
viewer up to this point full confidence
in everything you do because obviously
you're the captain like why would you do
anything
to betray it there's no way no way but
the first seeds of Doubt come here
because you know it's not how it works
you can't just reset things like how
many the Multiverse is littered with the
corpses of your failures that is the
story here like all you lore Hunters who
keep ignoring the actual story like the
story is the lore
anyway so it's it's one of those things
where lady is this is the second to the
third or near the last time you would
ever see lady at the end of lady's
journey and from being that friendly
person in the uh Universal stability
agency that not as many people saw
versus the other versions to to this
desperate committed willing to do
whatever it takes that's one of the best
scenes I think is the normal Universe
very funny so funny and it's so long and
like but the candy and it's a great
Scene It is a good scene but speaking of
good scenes
probably my favorite thing in the whole
show
now for the sake of me doing it but
it's great
you guys are sick of it but I know yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
on hand meal fiend oh don't
hand me if you dance I don't know this
man
in my life
oh what have you done what you've done
is fall right into my chapter
not faster than I used to be huh
[Music]
okay
you win
can I have my hand back
oh my God I think I broke something oh
oh please hopefully tell me I need help
desperately friend of mine oh close
confidence
I missed our exchanges of conversation
that's it
close yeah
hey back Payback
whose idea was it
to throw sand first who first had the
idea
did old mark
have the idea to throw sand in your eyes
because you threw sand in his eyes
did you have the idea to throw sand in
Old Mark's eyes or I guess not old mark
because old Mark tried to throw sand in
your eyes
and also
where'd the sand come from
did old Mark give you the sand to throw
in his own eyes did he even know well
she didn't no because you yeah exactly
anyway the this scene is wonderful
because this is one of those magic
things where you said there was a good
enough take and there was it was good oh
yeah no I it was you were right on this
one one of the times I was just wrong
and this is this is a thing where uh we
did we had a good enough scene but I had
the the previous one was a great take
but I took too long getting the the sand
that was a hard I like part of it wasn't
trying to get the sand out of your
pocket I had five knives on me that
whole thing I had to do this is a
miracle take this is this is one take
this one take there are no Cuts in this
entire take from what from getting up
off the ground there are no cuts and
there could have been there could have
been but this take was perfect
um and I asked for one more I was like
please we're running out of time but I
was like I know I can do it perfectly
I've got it all down and I'm gonna just
[ __ ] unleash this old man inside of
me
um and it's a miracle because it almost
was destroyed because what happens is as
this Captain's getting up like from the
ground and moving over here to come here
I'm falling behind him he bumps this
pillar moves out of the way I pick it up
place it back get back in position and I
had to do it with the fake hand so I had
the fake hand in my hand I grabbed it
with the fake hand and my hand put it
back into place and then was ready to do
the the lunge with the fake hand and so
all of that just perfectly coincided it
was a pristine tank and you can tell
when I'm happy because with it because
I'm able to grab it I kind of like you
kind of even hear it in my voice where
I'm like oh please
oh gross confidence
right there
like that's me being actually excited
that I got the the sand which was
actually crumbled cereal it's amazing
too that like the focus is as good as it
is
okay on film set there's someone who is
in charge of pulling focus of focusing
the whole time right they have this
little tiny Monitor and they have a
little dial that they and they just do
it by feel it's incredible she had me
try to do it and it was like I don't
know how the hell they do it just
practice Yeah but normally like the
camera's static or the camera's doing a
nice sweep but the cameras are human
Mark is sprinting around the camera's
sprinting around there's no consistency
and so the whole the whole thing it's
just like
it's incredible yeah no the guy who did
it Matt was just like a hero the only
reason this scene works is not because
like I did well which I did but because
yeah and he said it was fun because I
was like I'm so sorry that you have to
do this and he's like it's better than a
car commercial like yeah I know right
the reason it's cereal is because sand
could actually be damaging if it gets in
my eyes you did you ever talk about
oh no I didn't we didn't get to that
yeah for the snow in Frozen Mark uh I
actually inhaled some of the snow that
was on me which was at first just
plastic snow and it got in my lungs and
I was coughing for like 15 minutes right
people thought we were gonna be done for
the day yeah um and then we changed it
to Salt which is much better yeah so
that this is why safety is important
thing so so if if there's snow usually
sometimes it's plastic snow but that if
you inhale it's very bad if you use real
sand not only does it take a face full
of it yeah it gets thrown at you yeah
not only does the sand not look as good
on camera like cereal because it kind of
like has big and small pieces so it kind
of clouds
um it looks better but yeah uh it's it
can be dangerous they're probably still
that plastic in my life with all the
micro plastic I'm fine anyway good dude
I'll stop you don't move don't do
anything whatever you do unless that's
what you did and then do it I dare you
to do it whatever you do do not do it I
love your expression here Captain I
can't let you win this is the final
confrontation good versus evil the hero
this is the villain justice will prevail
this day
first I need to test out the Event
Horizon protocol
the hand
I you know I just kind of had this
realization about the way that I write
and the way that I always mess with you
guys is that I do things literally to
mess with you ninety percent of the time
like I wrote this dialogue in this scene
the hero versus the villain to make you
think it was actor and then I turned
around and I'm like you thought that was
actor
you idiot when I'm the one who wrote it
to intentionally trick you into thinking
that
the real actor Mark is me
in the [ __ ] actually you know it
wasn't even aftermarket first his name
was [ __ ] mark it was when we filmed
who killed Markiplier his name was
[ __ ] Mark that was his name
because that's the whole bit that's a
little bit Yeah but anyway lore Wise Old
Mark trying to stop you for something
that he does not know what you did
because Mark in the previous scene was
not in this room with you he does not
know in no circumstance has he ever
actually known what happened in this
room
and the sad truth of it is
he caused it
yeah that's the true secret it's all me
I'm sometimes an [ __ ] and sometimes
sweet as hell I thought a great singer
sometimes
it's all me
the only way to truly fix the problem
once
sorry about that so don't use it for
people but this scene doesn't do it for
people
yeah well the same it's the same it's
the same
it's the same
when you've tried everything else
it's really
got nothing left to try
um
I know
that's the point
s
foreign
um I think uh was for it to not be so
obvious because I am the only one with
an orange Beret on the ship except for
maybe an engineer crew or something like
that but it's like it stands out so it
needed to be like hidden it looks good
with the sweater you can change yeah it
can change I can change I can change him
unforeseen concert is yes reference to
Half-Life much like the Doreen scene is
literally a reference to half-life
oh the pain and suffering that you
caused I forgive you it's all in the
past or the future or um that that will
never be because I beat you everyone can
finally go and live their infinite lives
and peace
oh
ah I bet you're confused aren't you or
maybe you're disappointed so you don't
get to destroy the universe
all that matters
you will no longer put the universe in
imminent Peril with your Reckless ramp
here those credits
big inspiration
very good
yeah I know that's why we're here
especially why are you here I thought
immunity to sing wouldn't shut up about
paradoxes
personal stability compromise attempting
to resolve probably just dinosaurs what
oh no no no no no no no no no no what
have you done hi I just saved the
universe from the captain's Rampage of
Destruction and apparently from YouTube
whoever you are
unable to resolve Paradox detectives
you did this it was you ready you're
gonna have to be more specific I've done
a lot of things infinite Paradox
detected Universal collapse turn it off
you have to shut it down you have to uh
well maybe that's not the worst idea in
the world
oh no you don't get your blower I'm the
one that blows Rings up
I love the eyes I love all of this so
cool yeah so this is this is just like
it's turned out exactly how I wanted it
right
to feel wrong
to feel broken because that's what
happens
the question that we should ask is like
this Crystal and that Crystal there are
the same crystal at different points in
time they cannot coexist part of the
reason why everything breaks is because
old Mark sends you outside of the
universe uh and doesn't realize that the
warp core follows
it does like um it's it's one of those
things where it's unintended
or unforeseen consequences to actions
that you think are trying to help things
inadvertently cause the destruction
there the reason lady appears here is
because your device your intact full
device in the previous scene
knows that the device on lady's wrist is
a paradox that is it from a different
timeline it cannot exist that causes
Universal instability and therefore it
purges it out of the universe basically
along with lady that's why lady goes no
no no no no no
and implodes
same thing happened with this warp core
except in macro scale but it no longer
has an outside the university even send
it to also this warp core was holding
open all of these multiverses all at the
same time which were all intersecting at
the CR at the epicenter of your ship
all of it leads to a really bad time for
everybody involved
um also this is not Captain Magnum no
it's not I'm sorry sad and sad to say it
guys like I know it
but it is the crew it is the crew yeah
it's the same actors it's the rest of
the crew but that's not Captain Magnum
do you think that's tall enough to be
Captain Magnum I'm sorry excuse that's
the the Jason Campbell the guy that
played the first mate I'm sorry
guys same hat but you know
it's a Multiverse
it's a Multiverse where he was Captain I
guess
anyway sorry guys you got a lot of
preconceived notions but if you just use
your analytical ability a little bit
you would have realized that you thought
that that guy wearing Captain magnum's
hat and coat was Captain
fool
they can't even get an obvious plot
anyway uh-huh yeah
look at all these wonderful people
there's many more things to talk about
in part two obviously but I say we have
the behind the scenes video ready for
you and what we're gonna do is we're
going to take a break a breather but
right now I'm going to play that for you
which means that you guys get to see
something that has not been seen before
and it will be completely unguided I
have not even seen it so if uh if the
editors put some horrendous things in
there and get my channel banned it's not
my fault
I am hereby surrendering all
responsibility you are seeing things
that I have never seen before and this
is a huge risk to do this but here we go
to do it you know what I mean oh it's
not Laguna
it's not for an entire year we can watch
those videos before they went out I
watched the majority of them I mean
so anyway we're gonna we're gonna I'm
hungry
uh so how long is this this is uh let's
see don't say how long out loud now we
know okay okay cool okay cool all right
so you guys are gonna see this magical
thing that nobody else has ever seen
and we are gonna go this might be loud
I'm gonna drag it right into uh OBS
um which might cause horrendous problems
but I like that let's destroy the
universe a little bit here and then
actually let's let's just make this big
and then
okay this might be loud turn down your
volume just a little bit I just I don't
know how loud and then just accordingly
okay
hey it's me Marlo was me Markiplier
right here with another crazy adventure
in space with me Markiplier happy to
have you on board let's have some fun
come on best part of waking up is going
to space with my heart chica's Happy
chica's excited
just happy and excited Henry's happy and
excited Tyler's happy and excited wag
your tail
yep there it is keep the camera on Anna
she's got always really pretty eyes and
she's just on top of things
you have a volume knob use it what do
you mean you have a volume
I mean I would say
one person could turn it down a little
instead of 30 000 people turning it down
I feel like
was trying to watch that
it's good it's okay so hey it's me
Marvel whoa it was me Markiplier here
with another crazy adventure in space
happy to have you on board all right
let's have some fun come on best part of
waking up is going to space with Mark
chica's happy chica's excited
just happy and excited Henry is happy
and excited Tyler's happy and excited
wag your tail
yep there it is keep the camera on Anna
she's got always really pretty eyes and
she's just on top of things she's you
know a great fun person
and she's super sweet she's hard working
head starts hurting I know
my scalp with bobby pins and then I keep
you coming back
his fault it's your fault I do you wrote
it I didn't design the looks oh but you
wrote it what and you approved it
you know
don't kick me in the nuts
doing crazy stuff you hear that crazy
stuff I really want to put the green
screen behind you when you're talking so
people can insert stuff I was doing
crazy stuff
crazy stuff as you can tell chica is the
center of attention on set always
and the bridge
without the monitors four days ago
what monitors
it's a bob how's it feel to be a team
Fortress character
which team closures he's been in and out
of dinosaurs
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should wow that's great I'm
capturing the god that is Bob right now
[Music]
and you're not in the scene I'm not okay
I'm good perfect that's what I was
hoping for okay
on speeds Mark rolling rolling
wave them in the air like you just don't
care
[Music]
[Laughter]
you'll look over see that there's Mist
coming out here look back to him uh
that's no good Captain I gotta go check
on ads good luck with that
yeah exactly and then just like decision
time
[Music]
life happens no hide back behind the cup
control
foreign
[Music]
wise socialite
see what years will do
years experience
[Laughter]
quite a look
it's called fashion look it up
welcome to the new Bob Ross painting
with ammunition
I don't want him to be lonely it's our
secret these are your bullets you're
looking as dirty as you want to it's
your words
[Music]
hey Pam
oh yeah
[Music]
I'm just saying hi just looking at you
look at this room
I'm gonna go run around on set and make
people uncomfortable by shoving a camera
up their butt
oh
for all the viewers out there that is
some delicious matte butt is a butt
patch
hi captain
everything's great
nothing's wrong in the world hey look at
my butt oh
haunting
[Music]
hi how you doing you guys look fantastic
yes
a little left
and now both these are tiny step forward
[Music]
please
[Music]
oh and they're low rise
you're hiding half of them with the
Poncho what do you suggesting I suggest
to help your palms that you either tuck
it in or yeah pull it pull it up
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God the captain is amazingly cool
thank you
letting me the tacos
[Laughter]
how are we gonna go
crazy
[Music]
wow
[Music]
I hate you so much you're human garbage
I don't really mean that you're a very
nice person I think that's it cool
while you're here
well you're still alive
[Music]
you really rock that knob Leo
[Laughter]
after all that
life why you're old I don't know you've
been around did I grow them you've been
hiding in the weird pockets of the ship
so you got a bunch of stuff I'm hiding
in the work car what was in there only
you would know
because I built it
the teeth get yellow as you age
you think on a spaceship he got veneer
old Mark is nothing it's not pink
[Music]
clean off
oh my God
[Music]
Amy
why is it Mark's fault
it's more fun why is it Mark's fault
Anna what why is it Mark's fault
oh my God
big weird brain
why is it Mark's fault
[Music]
he stole our frilly socks
it's Mark's fault because of all the
Markiplier promises I've never had a
Markiplier I promise ever
why is it Mark's fault
it's actually chica's fault and I would
have gotten away with it too if it
weren't for you meddling kids why is it
Mark's fault because he never wants my
fans but he always takes everyone else's
fan and they're cute little pants
yeah look look at this little this is my
phone oh what a dick Leo why is it
Mark's fault
um
uh
I don't know who is Mark that's a good
answer why is it Mark's fault I don't
want to answer that you don't want to
answer what
what I don't know what to hurt me but he
won't hurt you have you not seen him
pretty
because the story is about Mark he
thinks it's about the camera or whatever
the viewer it's about Mark it's all
about Mark it's all just an excuse
more attention
people who really know know how he is
it's exhausting why is it Mark's fault I
don't know she's been marked Division
I think that's the root of the problem
it is Mark's fault because he is a coach
of culmination of all the things that I
don't know he sucks
we just did rehearsal for when Mark
throws me around like a rag doll and
then I get to beat mark up
that's the face of someone who deserves
to get it
Mick what's going on with Pam I mean we
all know this answer but Pam is talented
but she's one of the laziest people you
know she's like a narcoleptic or
something in fact dude
she's blocking half the pathway
that's ridiculous I wanted to get your
reaction on camera you did this to me
this nip slip you busted you busted out
my suit you Janet Jackson dirt yep
what do you got to say for yourself
we have actual footage
this is what I gotta deal with here
[Music]
chica who is the most dangerous person
on this set in a fist fight rigged
question I don't have fists could you
defeat mark [ __ ] Please could use the
most dangerous person in a fist fight
please
[Music]
I gotta ask you
do you want to just come to my house and
do this every morning absolutely I think
you'll be very
like confused and turned on by yourself
that's the goal yeah I want to [ __ ]
myself
[Laughter]
am I looking yes
it's like Wade but yesterday is that
what I looked like I looked at myself in
the mirror and I was like this is not
mean [ __ ] to you I don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
and he feels beautiful I do feel really
pretty you are pretty much
[Laughter]
that's it
yeah copyright what's your favorite room
or part of the ship the prior room
because I can make that thing completely
fogged out white and then you can hide
in it and jump out and scare people
regular cut to the big fogged out room
when or whoever's editing this because
I'm not an editor I don't know what I
said
Hannah
what's your favorite part of the ship my
favorite part of the ship oh that's a
really good question the warp core
hallway it looks really good the
lighting's really good I feel like that
was the part when I walked onto the set
the first time that I went like like
seeing like all of the different
textures and the pipes and the lighting
and just how everything kind of fell in
there felt very much like classic like
alien ship it would have to be the
bridge man it was the coolest coolest
part for sure
I really like life support because you
know I had all the greenery in there and
it was like I don't know it was like the
only place where there was plants
growing on a spaceship what's your
favorite part of the ship
um
the warp core it's a giant phallic
symbol I mean oh yes yes
what's your favorite part of the ship
the props
makes sense it makes sense accurate my
favorite prop though is the big red
button beautiful what's your favorite
part of the ship costumes
what's your favorite part of the ship
maybe the warp hallway when it's already
gone absolutely no question
or the lockers I like the lockers
they're they're practical
my favorite part is the hallway into the
warp core that's a very common answer I
think that's gonna win the overall poll
yeah yeah
so impressed with the lighting and the
set design yeah yeah and no place to
hide audio uh yep my favorite
but aside from cryo I'd have to say it's
every part on the outside of the ship
anything that's not the ship space you
know space is my favorite part of the
ship Bob hi what's your favorite part of
the ship yes
[Laughter]
what's your favorite part of the ship
yes
rehearsals up let's get our first
positions please there you go only this
one because we could have smoked out you
know right now it's pretty calm but we
uh when it was fully active it had dry
ice and I think this was a dope probably
the Ryu getting cold up in there getting
cold and we got some hot people so
sometimes you go in there to cool off
all right
Jordan just the man I was looking for
what do you need captain Oh Captain of
mine
we only have the ship for a few more
days that's not true
but what's your favorite part of the
ship captain I'm gonna work for hallway
100 it's a popular answer it's a winner
it's the best looking 100 oh yeah well
it's your favorite part of the ship
oh oh
sorry what's your favorite part of the
ship leave it in the comments below
don't forget to like And subscribe yeah
hit that thumbs up button
[Music]
I'm here in the airlock this is a
special message for Mark and Amy
thank you
I didn't plan out what the messages I
just want to take a sec to say thank you
this is very self and grandizing and
self-important of me but they gave me
the camera and
it's something that I would struggle to
say in person to both of you and to Pam
and Mick and everyone on the crew and
everything but
[Music]
but this just been so fun
anyway it's been really fun and I feel
like it's something I have never got an
opportunity to do uh unless you invited
me to do it so thank you
um
foreign
for the whole thing so I guess I'm kind
of sad but
thank you
[Music]
what do you think this man is somebody
who's published a tasteful nudes
calendar tasteless I say hey tasteless
maybe a tree I
you
eat I am right under here yep I probably
smell like bacon wrapped in leather left
in the Sun for six days
oh what am I walking in on what time is
it business time oh I'm sorry here it's
just time to party party is that is that
right oh it's time to party
it's also like 3 A.M
it are we ready
apparently we're ready you bring your
pipe with you you don't want it your
pipe
um
[Music]
great love it
[Music]
ah
where's my dude
[Music]
oh look at him this is like
cookies
nice sharp eyebrows oh yeah killer
eyebrows one would take it
[Music]
this place looks awesome
oh dude
[Music]
you're looking a little old
[Laughter]
yeah
you take the photo yet
do you know what BTS is
[Music]
[Music]
is never a fan of dying but I'm really
not lying when I say that I don't mind
doing it with you and you and you and
you and you and you and you and you and
you the last goodbye
[Music]
begin to a million stars
[Music]
I love it so much it's so good that'll
make Far Cry
thank you so much
you know you have the other one it's
been hanging up on my own
[Music]
it's been wonderful it's not done yet
not done yet
that's the one
[Music]
[Applause]
I could thank every one of you
individually and I will there's one
person I want to thank
definitely which is our company who
sacrificed his own neck to make sure
that this project off the ground thank
you Amy thank you so much
Isaac my shouting voice is booming
Thundurus called every one of you did an
amazing job and
and it's just such an honor that so many
of you fell in love with the project too
I mean it's one thing to ask you to like
bring my stupid imagination to life but
it's another to see people really enjoy
it
'll be very special yeah I hate speeches
but I just I love all of you so thank
you so much everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
man who is cotton onions
well who's cutting onions in here
sweet that was very sweet I we actually
didn't see that so it's it's kind of
we just had it on our phones in the
kitchen yeah yeah
yeah
um
I gotta watch that again I know we
missed some of it
yeah that's very sweet uh thank you to
you know the editors
Lexi and Marcus Rachel for making that
and everyone who filmed it as well you
know Pam Tyler and Evan and you know
various people on the crew that was very
sweet that was a very
that's very nice I feel like that was a
good look to it like the actual behind
the scenes what it looked like yeah that
was good and Bob's a freaking message in
there I thought it was gonna be a bit I
thought so too you know you never know
he's like oh I'm you know I couldn't say
this to them in person yeah you never
know with him but no
but knocked out it's very nice
that was that that's what makes uh all
this so fun is is being able to make
art no you know what I not even
sarcastically this I'm extremely proud
of this
this is Art
um to me it's it's something that moves
you makes you feel something and when we
get into part two you know it's uh it
really brings all that together and I
think that's very special it's you
telling like a story in a message that
you care about yeah exactly and a lot of
people cared about that that was the
thing me saying that at the end of like
people fell in love with it they did
what wasn't apparent is like there was a
day on set where everyone dressed up as
me the last day yeah it was a big secret
and and I had no idea it was coming and
then just show up on set and see
everyone dressed as me and my either my
various different looks or just how I
showed up on set when I wasn't in
costume
I was a very sweet yeah really good
people oh and dressing up as characters
that like weren't even in space that
were like yeah other characters you've
done yeah I know right oh just very
sweet there's this one moment where
Jordan I I remember so distinctly
because it was so weird right who put
them up Tyler Tyler put him up to this
so Jordan uh was the captain you know he
he had the whole rig on his head
um and uh one day we were in that Diner
and we were waiting for them to set up
something or other and uh like if if
this was me he just came up to me like
this
so um
what were you like in high school
you know just like really really really
weird I'm like uh you know it's kind of
a nerd I guess you're not very talkative
and then he pushed it already like yeah
so like you
guy
jock like you know I'm I started being
weirded out rightfully and I went you
know um
it's kind of a loner you know I didn't
like talking
I look at him real strong
he's like
so what kind of stuff you wear and it's
cool you know
what'd you do for fun like
it just literally was like
yeah you know usually I just like to be
alone
and then I walked away and so I knew
that this was happening and then Jordan
comes up to me and he's like I think
Mark's really mad at me he was like he's
like I think I upset him but and then we
get in the car I saw like I was like oh
I knew that he was probing for like to
figure out how to dress like Mark
because he's like I'll be Mark like when
he was younger yeah and then we'd get in
the car to drive home you and I and
you're like Jordan was being so weird
today yeah
you were playing it off
yeah I'm worried he just came after you
started asking these really weird like
what questions like about my high school
account how I dress very strange you
know it's just like but Tyler put him up
to it because of all people that knew
how I dressed in high school Tyler knows
because he was there anyway so there's
whatever all right we have a big group
picture of everyone just as you have to
find it later he's one of all the girls
because I couldn't I wanted to post it
but I couldn't because I had my alien
stuff on and so it would have been
spoiled it right right right
okay so what we have now is even more
shows we gotta go to part two baby if
you have not seen part two yet you gotta
go now cause we're gonna spoil it all
for you
right here right now part two baby show
we barely got through any of part one oh
my God by the way if you do want to
watch this
um and you've seen it already before
watch it with a friend you know I I
joked about the whole like tie a friend
down and force them to watch it but
really my favorite thing was watching
people play with other people it is it's
fun when we had friends over for the
friend premieres of the show we had
people making choices do round robin
with your mom too my mom was there yeah
was there for the part two friend
Premiere it's it's fun it really is fun
also a goddamn Delight to watch it with
all them because it's like Mick and Pam
it's like the perfect group of people
who like have been there since date yeah
so they like know every joke and like
every like and we've watched it like you
know the crew Premiere and stuff like
that and like a lot of these jokes are
like six years old you know so a lot of
it like does go over other people's
heads which is totally fine like I think
it's still fun even if you don't get any
other references yeah but it's so fun to
watch with people who are like
like the gym scene and [ __ ] yeah the gym
scene God it made everybody laugh it
made me laugh for like a five minutes
straight it's so funny because like
we'll talk about more when we get to it
but I talked about with the members also
thank you to the members for supporting
the channel and helping fun projects
like this because we went way over
budget many times and you know glad we
were able to afford a few more bfx shots
um but yeah I talked over like it's hard
to do physical comedy with CG things
that is that one of the few examples
I've seen of CG things being just as
funny uh in terms of like physical
comedy anyway we're going into part two
now
buckle up last chance bail out if you
want to watch it for yourself also
cloakbrand.com special posters are
available there limited edition merch uh
not going to be there for long uh other
people on YouTube have played it
bro did a video bro
go if you see anyone doing reaction
videos or streams send them some love
because we love watching people play and
if you want to record yourself playing
it we would love to watch it yeah it's
not like something that we're gonna like
take down it's there for it's there to
play it's for you you make Let's Plays
like you're not going to tell people not
to play your like game exactly exactly
exactly all right part two here we go
wait what here we go
a little bit of a dishonest feel too
oh it's a one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I want to pause here I wanted to watch
it more interrupted but I wanted to talk
about another factor of being able to
work with people that really do love the
show and want it to be great
um if you saw on the BTS video you saw
that Adam there loved the big button he
was the prop Master for the show I could
go to him and ask for anything and in
this particular case in my written
script it was just a glitchy version of
the original scene but we saw an
opportunity to do something creative I
was like what if he's hanging out the
window like outside that that'd be
probably the weirdest interpretation of
this and so I went to Adam and I was
like do you have any like this is a long
shot do you have like a a severed hand
or something in a prop in a prop bucket
somewhere it was like
well I think so I got severed fingers
too if you want that and I go
I will take the severed fingers yes and
I was like Adam Duty he always had [ __ ]
like that just waiting to go because the
prop department has their own truck on
set right they bring all their props so
it's not like they have all of their
stuff
but he he carried around the [ __ ] that I
guess he knew that you might have
thought I might ask for and that was
what's beautiful what about you did use
a lot of like fake arms I did it was
like one or two times that he could not
get something that I asked for
um and it's like that's a testament to
him and and just like the amount of
stuff that he was ready for and also
like him understanding the show he is
the reason all those mugs had so many
different versions there was written a
few different versions for mugs in the
show but that was like four times it was
different there was like 20 or something
mugs in total so uh yeah no blood though
oh I'm sorry I didn't want to get blood
on this nice set but yeah no blood he's
uh the fingers are pulled from the
vacuum of space the blood thing was a
thing uh for the crazy Mark stuff right
yeah
marks all over everything but it's like
because of the way the you know
scheduling worked it was like well we
can't draw all over the set because we
need to keep filming on the set yeah
that's why it's like pieces of paper
instead which is fine which is fine it
works yeah anyway continuing
over here you like bratwurst
bratwurst like like a like a restaurant
I'm thinking maybe you and me we can go
pop out there
welcome aboard the invincibility glad to
have you here took you long enough let
me give you the grand tour before we
Embark
my baby
remember
his father
[Music]
stop the heart and soul
I've yet to meet a problem that can't be
solved with explosives and speaking of
explosives
do you think she had the right idea
captain
did you give up or did she move on
I suppose
[Laughter]
come on slowpoke
all that's left now
I want to pause for a moment because I
want to talk about
the concept of
bang for your buck almost not worth
doing for how little it'll be used
because if you really think about this
shot and this segment of this scene
every single person in this shot is
glorified
that took time that took time to get
that and you see it for maybe a sum
total of a couple seconds in this like
the time it took and we did this but we
did this because it needed to feel and
we had everyone there only on one day to
do this hallway shot but you see like
you see cells here with this like this
code everyone's got a hat and everyone's
got this and everyone has different like
manners and that's the time to talk to
them like this is easy you just fall
down change lighting I don't know if it
was in the behind the scenes video but
the captain like the camera rig also has
a fedora on it which you never see but
just a fun thing it really is yeah
that's very good but all this took a
different plan like every single person
there has different one Bob has a
different one you know some people have
guns some people like I'm being handed
to Whiskey glass instead of the uh the
tablet from the beginning like all this
is like it's Autumn like this I didn't
think of everything but we collected
oh
is for you to say the word try not to
get them too excited Captain I know how
your speeches can get people riled up
Captain why does it seem familiar
Angels head long into the spiraling
chaos of dimension of Calamity heralding
the beginning of the end
what an adventure I swear this story
never ceases to amaze me by the way
or for the first time depending on your
past choices either way I'm sure we'll
meet again for the first time in the
very near future and or somewhat distant
past
should this not prove to be the end of
all reality which it almost certainly is
it would be my great pleasure to guide
you through my own Universe should the
opportunity arise
which doesn't seem likely to happen this
juncture but when thinking in infinites
unlikely there's just certainty waiting
for its turn
foreign
sport
so yeah so fast and notice how he's so
polite he knocks on the door before
opening it because he respects
the boundary
this oh man
God
[Music]
what a what a trip you know this is
really an epitome of
if people don't trust that I kind of
know what I'm doing
this this makes no sense in his like why
this was a traditionally made thing no
it would never be it would never happen
because like what is this yeah like oh
this is a character from a GTA video
that I made a one-off like you know what
I like I made like three episodes of
this you know it's not my most popular
but it's got a niche audience you know
it's like
it would never get approved which is why
it was like that's why I so think
YouTube is such a unique place like even
outside of YouTube Originals the ability
to do things like this craft your own
worlds and like scoop things in and push
things out and make things and transform
things just like oh the reason you have
gloves because like so in Heist
um you know something that we tried to
pay attention to the best we could is
having like different types of hands
right like different genders like
ethnicities right so we had a variety of
hands so like it always felt like
the U is not like one you it's all of
you
um but the captain has gloves so this is
the only time where you would have ever
seen your hands right okay we can't just
have one skin so they happen to have
pink and blue gloves and you'll notice
like it's the altar dark applier
people people were like red people were
like oh my God it's red it's like it's
clearly pink clearly but even like the
socks kind of like the nightmare about
the spaceship again
it's alternate color socks so it's like
right hand pink glove left foot pink
sock it's just like it's so cute
I saw it wasn't even my idea to do I
remember like I don't know if that's
gonna translate but it's like what else
but what else would you do so I like let
it roll for the first few takes I was
like we'll see how it looks on camera
and if it doesn't work but then it was
like yeah
it works that one just keeps coming back
doesn't it well I know just the thing
that's going to cure that another story
all right well let's see what we got
here
maybe a little too grizzly uh I read
that one too many times
not in the mood
not today
[Music]
why don't you decide huh you could read
a nice romance story that'd be fun or a
horror story I know how much you love
scary stories but it might give you a
few more nightmares so
you can go romance it'll be a little
silly and more than a little sappy but
it might be just the thing to kick your
right back to sleep
well whatever you choose I can guarantee
it's going to come with a big old hug
free of charge
uh so big shout out to Schmo Yoho let me
get the poll up
uh big shout out to Schmo Yoho because
if you could hear the sound there it was
a child's version of dumb boom boom
um also and you know I said I was going
to get to this later in in part one but
yes for those many of you got this this
is actor Mark
um you can tell bye
[Laughter]
are you seeing he connecting the dog oh
no go go on yeah yeah this is this is um
uh this is post parole
axramar he's really trying to sleep
no it's just
I'm sorry I make no one laugh more than
myself
okay uh looks like Romance by a good bit
which is good because like this is my
favorite of these two anyway once again
playing yes it was straight up reference
to date and you'll see another reference
to date earlier or later on or earlier
you know time flows backwards here or
whatever
um but yeah it's like I knew people
would go this for the dark path uh but
Romance
it's not actor it was a joke it was a
God I should never have said anything
because people are gonna take that
seriously you can take whatever you ever
you could think whatever you want to
think you know that me saying that is
just a valid uh jump and a conclusion as
you guys should jump into conclusions
right my universe
oh all right
all right the best we don't want you
getting any more nightmares now do we
have at skywater for a spell oh and
speaking of which spent at least an hour
since you last hydrated so be sure to
drink up champ
okay romance I've never read this one
myself uh not really one for romance or
at least that's what your mother used to
say
right before the divorce
that's not important right now
Okay so
The Story begins
[Music]
bonjour
I got you something roses so good to see
you again I can't wait for our second
day okay yes this is a complete
uh reference to date but the funny thing
about this scene is like I had to look
up how I said the word roses
oh I got you something a rose just like
I said it's so weird so I wanted to say
it the exact same way washing date
yesterday
it's so funny still funny still funny it
like it still works really well anyway
I know that our first one got a little
away from us but this one will be
you'll see a movie or ride roller
coasters or pretty much whatever you
want did someone order a large pizza
extra
pepperoni I've got tonight all planned
out we can go to the carnival and share
cotton candy and maybe even hold hands I
hear your Plumbing's clogged mind if I
uh
inspect your pipe I rescued this
adorable puppy from a Burning Tree just
this morning now we're best friends I'm
writing you a prescription that you're
gonna need to take several times a day
it's my kitty wink and I adore you drink
okay this scene has simultaneously one
of the best jokes I've ever written and
one of the worst people the stop-com
sign it might be it's so it's really
good Amy's like was asking me yesterday
if you came up with that
yeah I'll take credit for it but you
know honestly just like it's so goddamn
good just also the worst in that I I
wrote a little thing in here as a test
to see if YouTube was still reading my
scripts that I was sending them you send
them updates because they wanted to make
sure that you're stop working on it and
at a certain point they stopped sending
notes back about the script itself uh
that was about halfway through part one
um so as a test when I sent over the
part two script I left in a line that I
knew would not fly for the final show or
I had a really big feeling that it
wouldn't because they attend notes like
uh certain like curse words they were
more okay with than others things like
that yeah it's like one of the examples
is like when I say
take that Oppenheimer you old sack of
[ __ ] uh originally I was take that
Oppenheimer you old [ __ ] and they were
like yeah you know we don't like they
were like [ __ ]
I'm saying this about a man but yeah but
it's like totally fine so I was like how
about old sack of [ __ ] and they were
like perfect great awesome and I went
all right cool
um but this line
it's my kitty wink instead of a wink
here in the script I sent over I wrote
[ __ ]
and they didn't say anything and they
said nothing
so we filmed it so we filmed it we also
filmed a wink version you know just just
in case
but I literally wrote that in and they
said nothing which basically and they
never sent another note about the script
and it was in there up until the sound
mix like that was yeah when it was like
like the the scene was compiled together
for whatever I guess because it was in
the script as that that was the one that
like kept getting used and so we get to
the sound thing and we're like that
can't that can't still be there we need
to change that shot yeah so we changed
that out to wink because it's like the
joke is already there it's like you know
I need more of it anyway also in the
next scene super happy to get
the legendary Robert Rex living legend
icon
um
no you can't see the other one
how many times do I gotta tell you to
stay out of my kitchen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hey watch it
we wouldn't want to have an accident now
would we
thank you darling
sure is pretty anytime sugar
baby
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop what
are you doing what are you doing what
are you doing I'm trying to get back
there
the aliens were fun because like all of
us just turned up and they were like we
have a whole bunch of costumes we're
just gonna throw [ __ ] on you until we
think it looks right
yeah super fun what was great about this
is like I I know it was it was so fun
but there was also some things that I
knew were gonna come up going from part
one and part two let me tell you
straight up the ideal version of the
show is not split into two parts
splitting into two parts was a
compromised it had to happen to get the
budget necessary to be able to make this
show in the first place an ideal and
even in the original version of it it's
one continuous Journey from top to
bottom [ __ ] huge it's still huge but
you know
um like a month in between is a small
sacrifice to pay to execute the vision
in the way that you can or you want to
at least
um and and well a lot of people were
saying I was saying it was like man you
know there's so much on the ship in part
one it's like yeah there is because
that's the story but here you know in
part two we get to really like go nuts
with it and go ham with it so it's a lot
more um like crazy fun and and where I
suppose like the ship's not like part
one's not fun it's like you get more
diverse locations this is like fan
service so you like it's almost like an
encore in the what'd you say it's like
kind of like an encore within the show
of just like we're just
we're just an adventure
would you look at that like just this
morning there was this stabbing
sorry old habits oh please be careful
that is my real hand or is it
yeah okay all right okay it is oh please
oh strong grip Captain just like I
remember and uh yeah it's good to see
you
I guess I
I guess I owe you an apology
I was wrong
I was wrong about a lot of things
to give up hope and you and all this
if I hadn't gone back or if I hadn't
tried to stab you
oops drop my knife
sorry about that
I'm uh
I'm tired captain
I'm very tired
I've been trying for so long to fix
things
I don't think I fixed anything at all
actually
where's yet
I think I'm the one that caused some of
this
are you all enjoying your dinner is
there anything I can do to
make it better
for what it's worth
you were an excellent captain
you never gave up on your crew
not even once
I wish I could have done the same for
you
it all seems so crazy now maybe if I had
gone back to the right time
maybe if I hadn't sabotaged this ship
maybe if I didn't go back in the first
place I could
if I didn't go back
if I didn't go back counting if I didn't
go back oh oh there's something you have
to tell me well not me right now the
other me the younger me you have to find
me and yeah
who's gonna pay for this
okay so I may I'm gonna make the poll
but uh while we do that there's plenty
to talk about in this one there's so
much happening in this one because it's
setting the scene right so number one
the robber X's the chefs the head
replacement I mean what the face
replaced I mean just like what could I
say
more about it it's everything is what I
want this is what I wanted to do with
Heist that scene with the chef in Heist
you know the path that nobody picked
because Yancey wasn't on it
with Wubba and Bubba the Canon ending
not really
oh Canon but
um
just delightful you know everyone here
delightful there's so much like stuff
that you're not seeing that you which is
like such a shame in this scene like the
elaborate costumes that are happening
back there that you never see yeah
there's uh this whole restaurant oh and
they're all eating real food
all the alien food they are all have
food in front of them and it's all it
all looks like alien food but it's all
edible there's like
yeah
[Music]
um
talking about the filming of this is you
know this is obviously a diner
um it's a real location dressed like a
real Diner so all we had to do was put
some alien gack on it
um the outside is just there's a black
Dove uh blocking out this is the middle
of the day that we're filming this by
the way so we got to make it look like
night and then basically those lights
back there like any of the lights that
you see going by there's two carts with
lights on them below the window line and
you have one guy
non-moving cart far on the right side of
frame here I'll frame here shining I
believe that red one
oh no the red one was the mobile and
then you see this this blue light is
just a guy on like a spotlight going him
turning it you slow fast slow it's
really really simple stuff that makes it
look
I don't know you suspend your disbelief
just enough that you're like okay I
could believe that this is a diner in
space and not a restaurant that we
rented out in the middle of the day you
know we can believe it we can believe it
these are not Windows these are big
black uh boards that we put there
posters there was stuff on the wall that
we couldn't take down so we're just like
okay we have to cover a lot of stuff
like yeah yeah a lot of limitations on
this set in particular yeah but you know
a lot of what um old Mark here is saying
is like is really pertinent as well and
you just go like you take it all of what
he's saying he's telling you the truth
about everything he's like I think I'm
the one that caused all this because of
course he finally encountered the idea
that he did this
and that's that's crushing
like it is it's sad oh also I know
everyone wants this mug I just heard the
universe and all I got with this stupid
mug
um
we can make that happen
everyone who has Twitter account tweet
at cloakbrand right now on Twitter uh we
want this specific mug like tell them I
want the I destroy the universe and all
I got was this stupid mug mug
or I am going to throw a tantrum and
then record yourself throwing a tantrum
as hard as you can in your room or
wherever you are if you're in the middle
of public right now if they don't
deliver it if they don't put it on the
website within 24 hours record yourself
throwing a tampon and then tweet it
add cloak so please I don't know why we
forgot about this one
it's just what it is now what does the
poll say
58 left 58 stupid am I right
yeah yeah no but there's stuff to talk
about that way no no no
wait is left his Mac right left his Mac
well I only wanted to talk about Max
original the original plan for Mac ah
it's a good you don't have to go I mean
we can go back I don't know
if you want to if you want to talk about
that I don't know if you want to talk
about that no I'll talk about that yeah
absolutely
um all right the people have spoken I
always I always listen to the Democratic
process you know I believe in the will
and the the right of the people
to go left so left is what we do
this is what the people have spoken
listen hey
you lost
it's it sucks I wanted to go right but I
listened to what you guys want the
majority anyway we can't go back can't
go tell me I can't go back tell me I
can't go back
software update complete good morning
Captain we are currently here he is into
our journey coffee is on route
current status is
absolutely catastrophic
protocol
problem captain
[Music]
computer damage report meteorite
impacted life support fire detected
Systems Failing whoa hold on there
captain no need to be so hasty
this is me looking at you making the
decision to go towards an inferior
engineer
uh Captain you feeling okay you you
you're making wise this Oh no you're not
okay anyway
um I will give you guys
a chance to guess who was originally
supposed to play this character
I will give you a guess
now is your chance to guess
so guess right now
there's some right guesses yes it is
correct it's it was supposed to be Sean
like Sean was supposed to play this
character knock off you like me
but also but also better than me in
every way you know what I mean it's like
the parallel like that was originally
the joke yeah yeah yeah
um but you know uh Sean couldn't come
over I'm not saying you know I hope
matbat isn't crushed that like because
he did a [ __ ] incredible job as Mac
and originally in the original script
there was actually three different
versions of Mac there was Mick muck and
then Mac and they were gonna be
progressively stupider versions of me
all from people that kind of looked like
me was a general consensus but whoever
really it was like Mick Mack and muck we
couldn't do it with Sean because they're
like kovid oh yeah travel was still
impossible yeah so
anyway so uh I think we've seen enough
here we can go back now uh he does a
terrible job nowhere near as good uh as
I am at being a good engineer so now we
can go the correct path the right path
uh towards what we actually want to see
Ethan would have been funny
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
love everything about this whole
sequence
I did not know this is where the the
makeup and wardrobe people just went
crazy they did this multiple times you
want to know why that actor scene is in
part one because they pushed for it so
hard originally it was kind of there I
think but way smaller way smaller scene
they wanted to go all out with that
scene so it was like because they were
like what if we're all in it what if
everyone did it it's like and every day
they were like you think we're gonna do
the aftermarket scene today oh they
pushed for like a week straight that's
week straight and finally we had time
and it was like this but this is another
example because I even in that behind
the scenes uh video you kind of saw it
with me and Ethan in the alien look they
would do things and then run it by me
afterwards when it was far too late to
do anything else like that was their
little strategy and I knew it was I
never let them know or they go to me
yeah yeah like
I was allowed to
say yes you know yeah yeah yeah and so
sometimes they'd have an idea that they
knew that you might not be receptive to
but I would be and then when you said
why the hell did you do this they'd say
Amy said it was okay yeah yeah I would
be okay taking the fall yeah but I I
remember walking in and I saw Tyler's
hair full Johnny Bravo maybe maybe even
taller than Johnny Bravo's hair it's
like Doug Dimmadome
to be off screen at all times truly yeah
that's how his hair should someone
should make an edit of this video with
his hair all the way up to the ceiling
from the way in the distance it's it's
incredible there's so much hairspray in
his hair right there how do you get it
out she's staying with us at the time I
don't know like an hour long shower most
of them but just like I love everything
about the sequence like a lot of these
little Windows into other universes are
are what they seem it's like what could
have been different choose your own
Adventures that I could have made I
really truly thought of a choose your
amateur called where in the world is is
Markiplier like that was an idea I had
these are all ideas I've had that I
didn't think could be fleshed out this
one could have been because oh my God
the style I the style
like the music of the feel Agent Mark
like oh my God
go enjoy look here
[Music]
bonjour Raise Your Arms
love the arm that was a last-minute idea
dude all clear bonjour have a nice day
sir we've got every single possible
agent on this already there's no way we
can add more I don't want excuses
yeah [ __ ] yeah this day my back was like
royally [ __ ]
um partially because it was already
getting strained I just did stunt day
with all the wire rigging uh the day
before and then also I fall later in the
scene that really [ __ ] my back up
after you fell that was when like Isaac
was coming to me and you were covering
because you didn't want people to think
you were hurt yeah but I was I was like
we were like we're on edge yeah I was
like oh I fell and then later on that
day when I stepped in the Wormhole
I stepped in the pothole going back uh
few things this mustache
and these eyebrows are the same
the same these are a mustache that got
cut in half and put on
like God I just everything about this if
this whole sequence is the most pure me
Choose Your Own Adventure it's so silly
it like Echoes off a heist imagine if I
actually did make Heist 2 this would be
it like I just love it so much
huh well I'll be damned well obviously
we have to pull you out of retirement
then again if anyone would have wanted
to catch this snake
it would be you
just don't make this personal
now I bet you're wondering how he
managed to escape from prison huh yeah
you and me both pal pull it up on the
main screen
Mark E plier that you never thought
you'd have to see his ugly mug again a
few hours ago this Maniac somehow
managed to break out of the most secure
prison the world had ever seen
next slide please
somehow the entire Eastern block of the
building vanished Into Thin Air in an
instant now the Mr E Plies learned some
magic before he has some crazy tick up
his sleeves and lots of which we've
never seen
it's almost as if he ever
God damn wormhole in his pocket and we
know he's still alive because he's used
this same crazy Tech to hit three
museums already
don't know where he is we don't know
where he's going to be
you don't even know what kind of fire
power we're up against him
can I get a coffee yeah no problem
we don't know
but I think you do
I can already see a plan cooking up in
that big beautiful brain of yours that's
why I respect you so goddamn much
what is it this is one of my favorite
choices I know right God I had so much
fun part two flowed so much faster than
part one well because it's just well
yeah because it's just like anything can
happen like I really wanted to open up
the floodgates of nonsense and the whole
concept is that the universe is breaking
apart so things mean even less sense
than they did before anyway let me get
the poll up here
um
give the people what they want
uh
I can't even spell it okay and it is In
This Very Room
hang on I'm very room
okay so
um and yeah like this is really what I
want and this is like why I I'm not
upset that it split into two parts
because the the alternative is that it
never would have been made in the first
place or it would have never been made
as good as it is so it would have been
half the size yeah because the way it
went is like it was big slightly bigger
than Heist
um at first and then it was too big and
they said we need to pare it down if
it's going to be one of these because I
had a contract with YouTube to do two
more uh choose your own Adventures
that's what I I had a contract to do
that
but then when I was making this the idea
was so big that they allowed me to
fulfill my contract get double the
budget for two shows for this show if I
split it into two parts they that is
something that I am extremely grateful
for with YouTube they allowed me to do
that to get more money to not only
fulfill my contract but also get the
best show out possible
I am super grateful for that so when I
did that it went from being slightly
bigger than Heist and that was too big
for one to Now
90-something videos I I thought it was
87 yesterday it was actually 90
something videos to 90 something videos
6 hours and 57 minutes run time that I
split into two parts to being like a way
bigger than that because you were like
oh no I have more budget and then you
just kept right and then I kept writing
more or really I just pulled in my ideas
I already wrote so like it went from
being slightly bigger than Heist to
being way bigger than Heist and so with
with part two I wanted it to reach a
story conclusion but also just be like
be more fun in general like have more
nonsense happens like just like complete
chaos across the board yeah okay looks
like you look like a lot a lot like
Markiplier is winning
now correct me if I'm wrong I just want
to be absolutely clear with what you're
saying you think that I the director of
an organization whose sole purpose is to
track down Markiplier notorious
international criminal wanted in 87
different countries is that very
criminal standing directly in front of
you is that what you really believe
I guess you really are as good
but it doesn't matter how good you are
it's too late not so fast Mark wow wow
if it isn't agent crap
oh no
I'm not agent crank no no it can't be
that's impossible it's Wubba and I'm
taking you down how could you do this to
me you wouldn't like a brother to me
that's right and you thought you were so
smart infiltrating this organization but
I beat you to the punch
clever
one he
forgot about one small important too
that's not possible that doesn't make
any sense
uncovering Mark's undercover operation
but little did you know that I was
Undercover the whole time triple
undercover no no that literally can't be
how are you you if I'm me isn't it
obvious well awesome
Wade was unrecognizable I know right
because you didn't know he was gonna
have the wig on right yeah just nuts
like nuts nuts how much of a different
human he looks like with hair and he
looked good and I'm not gonna lie he
looked pretty good that guy he looked
good yeah
oh man hmm seems like there's some bias
happening in chat I think that mods need
to initiate emote only mode for some of
these people are trying to influence the
decisions here and that's not what it's
about that's not what it's about let's
get it as a group no no no no no let's
get emote only mode going
to have that power maybe I don't know I
don't know
no no no no we're not about uh we're not
about this um that's not there isn't
there an emote only mode
turn email mode
I can't even do that oops never mind ah
oops
hmm
now the members are disable the chat the
members would be even worse you know
all right whatever
um what is it right by 54 all right I
like how close these are let's have fun
that's kind of fun
hello
hey hey Captain Captain how's it going
thank God it's you
don't know how I got in here
[Applause]
I know what's going on with the ship I
have all the answers the Wormhole the
Wormhole is causing all the problems and
if you open the door I can tell you all
the secrets
I got it
Captain
why are you open the door I can't open
it you need to open it
ten nine hey it is
I think darkiplier might be on the other
side of the store
wait I never saw the thumbnail for don't
open the door
that's so funny I think darkiplier might
be on the other side now something about
this video if she hadn't been such a
princess on set
I would have loved to have done a scene
in which chica is in the airlock right
that would have been in it like we
talked about that way afterwards would
have been a delight if you were like
you're looking at chica's dirt like
which I could have done but I don't know
we just didn't even think about it at
the time yeah no
anyway but imagine it just but what if
you open the door and dark you lead to
the dark scene you know
like the dark wink wink scene
maybe you wanna
open the door
hmm
yeah it's Mark doing the door voice I
don't know how people didn't
people didn't know that I thought it was
you yeah it's clearly me yeah I know
would you
um open the door for me you know [ __ ]
like that it's a lot of
lock that [ __ ] up
well Tyler it looks like the people of
slogans are
by the way you did just kill Tyler
foreign
[Music]
school yeah say hi don't worry about
them there's none too bright but I am
glad that you showed up
twice I think we're good
I volunteer for free
No cameras and I'm
and I thought I ain't stabbed nobody
since you uh went away to space camp
yeah yeah and uh one more thing I
I applied for parole
I thought about what you was saying when
we uh when you wrote me that last letter
and I
free
why not
oh yeah
oh just in case you showed up oh
so I want to pause here like yes this
might be one of the meanest things I've
ever done you guys feel like you're
robbed from a musical but I want to say
this scene
was not written when we went into film
originally Yancey was not here uh the
last goodbye
and and again if you have there are
people here being like well I see in
chat watching this for the first time if
you go watch part two why are you I mean
I get why but it's just like go watch
part two do it yourself first this video
will be here afterwards go see it I
didn't do this all for you to just watch
it with me go watch it with a friend
it's a good show it deserves to have
more people enjoy it blabbing is ruining
the experience it really truly is but
anyway this was not written in the last
goodbye was such a banger of a song The
Gregory Brothers Shmo Yoho they made it
that was the original uh video or a song
that they wanted for the video that
would be space was so cool the sad
somber song and I had to call them up
and I'd be like dude I am so sorry this
song is so [ __ ] good but it doesn't
fit that scene
so they shelved it but then when we had
like um I think it was also after Leo's
back got hurt we had a few things about
half a day for you all the time yeah
exactly and so I was like I have an idea
I think we can get a ANSI scene in here
and we had talked about it before no
because this partition took a few days
to build
yeah I wasn't gonna stop you your story
is better but oh right no
this was a plan for a while but the song
wasn't a part of it yeah that's right
never mind Yancey was always in the mix
he was I was always thinking okay no
you're totally right because the
partition were there it's the song
portion of it had an idea to use the
song portion and uh write it into the
joke of like not being able to talk
um
and we just decided Well I do remember
that
um the other producers were very upset
that you were like
oh they're like we should have gotten a
choreographer because like this scene
became more complicated than it was
originally supposed to be you're like oh
no we'll just go out and do a little
thing and they're like
we don't have time to do a little thing
we did a little thing you're like oh no
we'll just like do like like a lion kick
and they're like oh God and I didn't
understand what their problem was
because we got it and now like the the
extras they we all got it you know Wade
and Tyler they were part of it like we
all did it it was fine anyway so this
song fit really really well for this
moment and to make this bigger and more
special
um and then also you can't hear any of
it it's hilarious to me it is very funny
it's very funny so anyway also uh I I
know a lot of people are like we're no
way to space camp and as like oh Yancey
knows about us in space is like no he's
covering the fact that he helped you
break out why do you think he's going
wrote me that last letter but I mean he
does have warp core he doesn't know that
in both parts yes that was like my
favorite thing is like you know when the
first one it in Heist he has the
the map tattoo so this one he has part
one and then part two it's not Heist and
in space it's part one and part two nah
Yancey doesn't control the tattoos on
his body they disappear
anyway
station immediately
I repeat Universal stability compromised
this is not a drill
please evacuate this station immediately
Universal stability
I'm sorry I didn't think anyone's still
here
thought everyone was
lost
trying to um
if you guys want the NC as Lord to have
magical tattoos that change according to
the universe is changing around isn't
that what's happening you can have that
I will confirm that
had fun with that
stem the tides
oh my God
you're here
you you you
we have been looking
everywhere for you for your ship
and it was even
he was gone
in every universe
lost so how are you
here
how
do you think this
we use that to you who gave it to you
and also um give it to me if I need it
please
or I will shoot
if you just if you give it to me
I swear I promise I can fix everything
[Music]
foreign
foreign
fact here first of all here yes that is
the song from the 8 million uh
subscriber Milestone video yes this is a
reference to the crying Mark meme yes
that's pretty much the same shirt jeans
headphones song yep you got it we have
talked about and I think we were just so
overrun with the rest of the production
of like doing like the blue and black or
you know the foam but yeah yeah there's
a lot happening yeah but it's just like
it is here and functionally it works out
really well let me get the choice up uh
there's a lot to talk about in that last
one um but oh oh you gonna cry
yeah I'll do a little oh
baby blue
it's okay Mark you can cry
I thought more people would choose all
you could cry
that's very sweet anyway so all that
stuff there
um
as with most things the it's like chaos
and fun which is kind of the point of
the things I do broken up by the reality
of this situation the reality of this
situation is the universe is breaking
and the universal stability agency has
broken with it trying to stop it
but there's no stopping it because it's
a crisis which they can't even find your
ship right so there's like evacuations
going on uh nothing that anybody can do
but the only person left is Lady
and it's because lady like if you look
at lady's first encounter very nerdy
actually I I always wrote lady is like a
nerd of Earth culture kind of like
always a secret little cheerleader of
Earth like an earthweave that was like
the whole character behind lady like
that's why lady likes some like Earth
culture things and like knows a little
bit Earth culture and is excited
um at first but also there's something
horrible going on so lady's like yeah
like but also it's kind of like but
um lady obviously
uh has character development going on
but the order of which you see that
character development
um fluctuates over time
so
lady name I don't know what you're
talking about anyway that lady yeah so
anyway
um
as as going through like you can see
there's a big difference in body
language between this moment and the
moment when lady encounters you in the
warp coron is like I'm not gonna let you
do it I'm not gonna let you do it you
can also see by the state of damage on
the uniform that is like not as damaged
um because has not been through as much
how many damage like layers did we have
for a lady I think five five like normal
with cape this is stage two stage three
would be just after this in the action
Mark scene or maybe it's kind of similar
then I bandaged and further damage and
then eye bandage leg right like name
hand blown off like I think that's about
them yeah so uh no agent Atlas this is
what I talked about Marcus
um when he made the website is because
the username on the website that Marcus
made for the interim uh it says agent
Atlas but it's that's a play on words
for it's it's like haroldapolis but when
you abbreviate H it's hapless hapless
which is just like him using a word
being like you're a hapless agent but
you had to have a
that's not yeah
this this is not Harold apples but let
me tell you that it's not and it's in
one universe
anyway no lady's name is lady because
the whole time you're like that lady
like you know because like yeah Mark and
the captain don't know who they are
and then at some point a name was never
spoken and then and it was never it just
yeah exactly that lady yeah so what what
it amounts to is like it it's literally
a character where the name never comes
up naturally and that's just how it is
that's just what it is
um and unfortunately it's one of those
things until Leo picks a name yeah
there's no name lady for now lady
is good also I want to say uh Leo is
extremely happy whoever did the cosplay
oh the lady I want to tell you how much
that meant because apparently Leo has
never had someone cosplay in all of
Leo's years of acting and doing tons of
stuff has never had anyone do cosplay of
one of their characters so that was
really really cool and all the fan art
too has been really nice anyway so now
we're back on uh it's okay Mark you can
cry
pathetic but pedophile all right let's
do it
seriously should I say for this scene
you saw on the behind the scenes thing
it was like I shoved something in my eye
what I had for this scene
um which thankfully I didn't need in the
later scene uh I had what's called uh
it's a menthol stick which is exactly as
it sounds it's like a lipstick container
of Menthol and uh you put this under
your eye and the Menthol goes straight
into your eye and it burns like hell and
you tear up it's it's one of the common
ways that actors can get tears in a
scene and it's very useful especially
when you're like uh doing 12 hour days
of the same goddamn cry scene cry stick
that's what it's called cold cry stick
or a tear stick or whatever it is anyway
that was
amen
[Music]
I love the colors
take a look at that rookie
can I say something about this uh no one
knew I was gonna do that accent
and uh I thought maybe it would get a
chuckle or something dead silence
Dead Silence
I do the whole thing
Isaac yells cut I look around like
no one said a word they just went okay
Mark sure that's what you're gonna be I
was like oh man okay
that is a beauty of a bomb all right no
time to waste
perfect
all right must be pretty exciting though
right all those years spent training and
all that hard work is finally gonna pay
off and I know how much you've been
looking forward to your first bomb so
I'm gonna let you take the lead on this
one
no backseat bomb defusing from this guy
I'm not even gonna say it people I'm
just gonna sit back shut up and let the
master work
okay so I'm gonna guide you through
something here we're not gonna do a poll
I don't remember
I don't remember I'll know when I see it
yeah which one's longer this one
[Music]
um
saying about
that though what the um cutting of the
wires yeah oh right right right which
maybe will be in the bloopers possibly I
hope
um
so Jordan the camera operator is wearing
a big helmet rig right and he is and he
is
not he's looking through a monitor right
and I don't I mean it's probably not a
delay on it but the fine motor skills
needed to cut a tiny wire
attempting to do it through a screen how
many eight or nine how many twenty
twenty was it not many times not that
one but the one in the woods which is a
tragedy because it took him he got it on
the first try yes he did anyway so
um
we're cutting the blue wire
and then uh
[Music]
well
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
howdy newcomer he made it just in time
we're making s'mores would you care to
join us
foreign
[Applause]
wiener
well it's going to be a busy few months
for us so why don't we kick this Camp
off with a scary story you know a lot of
scary stories don't you you live them
with your parents
well what about you camper do you like
scary stories we've got plenty of them
we all have Darkness inside of us so why
don't we share
oh God oh God what did I do
okay so anyway this is an example of
something that was written in the script
that because people don't know what's in
my head
they had no idea what was coming in the
script it is not written scary
but it is so unsettlingly scary also for
those of you who thought that cutting
the red and the blue wire led to the
same thing you're wrong I'm gonna go
back and cut the red wire now
thank you
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
camper you made it just in time we're
making s'mores
do you care to join us
ah it's time for the Scout's oath
eyes none of us knew that that was going
to happen I literally it was another
situation this is way late at night
right so those are only overnight shoes
yeah and so we get a good take with him
blowing the horn by the way the horn is
like my [ __ ] sound in the world now I
have it on my phone I gotta make it my
ringtone
um and so we have a good one and so I
asked Amy for one more because I'm like
I want to try something so long to get
to this point it did take me so long to
set up but rolling one was easy yeah
there was a whole thing with getting the
fire to work like we were all like
pretty [ __ ] done with this scene we
were sick of it so I said like please
just one more I know I just like I've
got something else I want to try and I
told Tyler
secretly and all the other guys here on
the camp I told them like at the very
beginning one of these takes you have to
just scream into the horn okay and then
we got the good take with him with the
horn and I told him like
God's time scream like you've never
screamed before in your life and he
[ __ ] just
and I heard the laughter like I heard
because we're like you know 50 yards
this way
I was just like oh my God you know what
like the other pain in the ass of this
one was is when they're doing the oath
and you say no matter what or whom yeah
Jackson or it was gets or stands in our
way and I think who are whom and gets
and stands yeah is so as a matter of
what or whom that was tough to get
everyone to say things but then ice I
kept saying stands and in the script It
Was Written gets so everyone say gets
and I said stands and I was like okay
let's go stands everyone stands and
that's most people said stand some
people said gets I'm like okay let's do
gets
[Music]
I think you can hear it in one of them
yeah there's like a minor one person
getting it wrong yeah yeah but it's all
good anyway we're going yellow
I love this joke
[Music]
it's you is it that time already
away from them they're still figuring
themselves out those two quite the story
but for another day and I'm glad that I
ran in you because you've been avoiding
me
no
I spent
three weeks learning to actually flip a
butterfly knife
just for this scene
legitimately
I thought that I wanted I knew in the
script I had me stabbing one of my like
wouldn't it be cool if I had a butterfly
knife
and so I bought yeah a prop butterfly
knife and I spent
three weeks constantly practicing
oh do I have it um
it might be in the Texas box yeah uh
maybe should we go look really quick I
mean you can yeah yeah and and it was
just one of those things where I was
like okay if
if War snacks is stabbing something
and he is using a butterfly knife he
would have to be so casual about it
that I could do it without even looking
that's how good I had to get at it and
so I just kept practicing
yeah but all for just that scene on top
of everything else I was doing but it
was nice because it was like it was like
an idle thing that I could practice with
and just like something to keep my hands
busy but yeah ah no
ah damn it here I'll flip
twirl
stab because I had to catch it in a way
what I wanted to do is I wanted to catch
it in a way that I was holding it like a
pair of Chopsticks because I feel like
warfstash would have stabbed that way
you know so it's like it's just no and
then close it up from there so just
uh
hey
Henry
[Music]
chica
also guys if you haven't seen part two
yet uh go watch it Link in the
description why are you here why are you
here why aren't you scheduling time with
your friends to be able to play it with
them here's Chica Chica what do you
think
go watch part two it's my starring role
and I guess Henry's in it too
so why don't you go and watch it and
come back later to this because we're
spoiling everything you won't get the
lore you won't get the enjoyment out of
it you'll make me sad and worst of all
you'll make chica sad so go watch it
right now come back to this later
honestly we're probably gonna start
skipping over stuff there's just too
much to go through anyway
we're almost through it though we're
almost through
just to get to the lower parts
up anyway
more warstash
you've been avoiding me and now that I
have you right where I want you
I'm gonna book that interview and I
won't take no for an answer and I won't
take yes either no choices at all really
haven't had enough of those
could you hold that for me thank you all
right let's see if I have an opening I
don't know if you're a book very busy
I'm so popular
some people don't know that is an actual
nude calendar that I did make it's so
weird to think about some people don't
realize like
some things are not a joke that is a
real calendar but a lot of people do
know that I did that but it's like that
would even that was years ago four years
ago now
this is kind of crazy to think about
like yep I and I am butt naked I am butt
naked you know what I uh love about the
wharf stash like scene here is that like
I remember doing Heist and you doing the
darkiplier scene yeah and you being like
uh you like being like to the crew like
okay guys I'm gonna do this thing and
like just
you know yeah yeah sort of having to
preface it with like just I have to do
this bit like it's fine but everyone
loves Wharf sash everyone everyone does
which is what I've always known like
people who had this like still to this
day this hard on for darkiplier but I'm
like this this is who you want this is
this is my um uh Tom Bombadil of my
universe is Wharf stash perfect example
of that not no describe
whatever but this is like a good example
I'm booking you for October 30th 2019.
don't worry I'll come to you all right
don't run any excuses this time none of
this earth and the past is that in the
future oh I can't wrap my head around
this whole time you want anything figure
it out lovely talking to you
we're already running behind so let me
order you a rides into your previous one
seems to have been unfortunately stabbed
by an unknown assailant probably that
old man
you don't mind pink do you
all right
October 30th 2019 is the date that a
heist with markiplier was released and
in one of those paths is an Easter egg
with Wilford where he interviews you he
is that he's booking you an interview
that is in the past
but if you can't wrap your head around
it figure it out
you want to pull up yes I do okay yeah
okay so some of you sharp-eyed people
have noticed where this connects
foreign
I love this so what I'm showing you is a
clip from Wilford
mother loving worfstash
oh you're right
said get down
how do you not
stop playing games get your ass down on
the ground before I blow you right here
right now
away
Dave
and now
this is a scene we just watched
[Music]
it's you is it that time already
yeah
it's the second one of him in the side
you don't understand
the other one oh no because someone put
up like a yeah yeah a clip on YouTube
that has a ton of views now of like oh
look it's a reference but they don't
actually show the shot of the second
Wilford walking out of frame they don't
show it it's like
not show it
anyway
just a little showing off you know you
know
anyway
uh continuing on for this was just very
fun I I honestly am looking at this
scene this is one of my favorite
performances I've done of worfstash I
love the way especially at the end of
let me order you a ride because your
previous scene seems to have been on
like unfortunately stabbed by another
sandwich like just it's it's so it's so
worthless like not even understanding
that he's the one that stabbed it right
it's into a previous one sticks to have
been unfortunately stabbed by an unknown
assailant probably that old man like
even going for it so meta blaming the
old man who is very stabby admittedly
but doesn't even like it's not even An
Occurrence in his head it's just like I
I really love this scene like I really
really really do anyway
foreign
helps them Escape
you helped those monsters which means
that you are just as responsible for
what's going on I didn't have anything
to do with that
come on you're the most notorious
Wormhole bandit in the galaxy
you gave them this yes
then you can tell me where they are even
if I did have anything to do with that I
didn't bring you all so you can't even
do anything about it in fact I think
do you understand what is going on out
there
do you understand what's at stake
people are dying because of this
so there's nothing
all right
let's see what we do
pull Time full time and his Bandit
so oh story right lore God damn
uh you're seeing more of ladies
progression I'm listening no you don't
you don't have to live you don't have to
listen you know all this so you're
seeing more of ladies progression in
desperation to try to do it but also
you're hearing that lady is trying to
find the ship that's the whole point
like if lady thinks lady doesn't have
any other leads lady thinks find the
ship stop all this from happening
whatever it takes doesn't know exactly
what so goes on to try to do what they
know okay so interestingly enough
a lot of people are voting intervene and
I totally get that I understand that and
the scene that is in intervene is very
very cool but not enough people have
seen the Alternatives and when you see
it you are going to thank me
when you see it you're gonna thank me so
I am overruling and we are going to
sneak away
even if I could tell you where it was
there's no guarantee you show up at the
right time
this is the exact ball from Battle Angel
Elita the motorball yeah because it was
a lot of the same crew like that
department and stuff yeah Rooster Teeth
helped out with that and also uh Brad
the sound mixture did the sound mixing
for battle Angel Elita anyway
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at home ninja Brian
this we showed this to so many people
this is one of the things we showed the
most of anything an entire half day of
filming dedicated just to that scene and
so worth it and it's it's not like no
one's seen this side of it intervene
very cool the reverse reverse extremely
cool took just as much time to film as
this but this was like a half a day all
of the instruments that they rented for
all of the costumes my God
I mean
but also the most fun day on set the
most fun and I did so little that day I
was so I I just got to enjoy it because
I wasn't in it and I just got to be like
you go change for an hour and uh and
then come out and every time they just
be in like a funnier costume than the
one before
so funny everyone had a [ __ ] field
day this is why if you haven't seen this
show we're not obviously not gonna show
it all now go check it out there's so
much fun stuff there's so much fun stuff
see you're thanking me I knew you'd
thank me I knew it anyway I'm on a
guided tour this from now on
we are here at the scene of the crime
where the perpetrator has returned it
might it be possible that set criminal
mastermind may have speed s be ready to
confess their heinous crimes
what boss did you have to destroy the
entire Multiverse boy did you obtain
such a reckless disregard for human and
unhuman life why did you feel the need
to end the existence of all that exists
and most importantly of all which one of
us is the real gym
dude
so few people have seen that last gym at
the very end gym
[Laughter]
uh I love the fact Jim is such a unique
Niche I know part of my channel but that
scene
everyone loves that scene
Jim
it's just oh God it's so Niche but I'm
so glad people here have seen the actual
like four gym videos have you seen the
four-part gym series I don't know I
don't think that they unlisted they I
think they probably are I don't know man
very cool though very fun anyway guided
tour
all right skip over this crap we don't
need any of this nonsense all right Skip
Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip all right nope
that's not what I meant to do God damn
it no no no no no no no we're here for
the lore
God oh no wait that's what I want
okay
come down
okay
[Music]
can I just say
um I knew people would were upset in
part one when you didn't get to eat the
donut and I I knew in my heart like oh
my God they're gonna be so happy that
they get the cookie
the same
oh man it's been a while
I'll come back
oh look buddy that is so sweet but you
know your cooking will kill me
all right
anyway I am so glad you're back I don't
know what you did but it has been so
freeing
opening wormholes has never been easy I
can go wherever I want whenever I want
I've been able to see some things that I
I thought I lost
[Music]
oh
yes that means you gotta go now
I know this probably isn't even real
it's wild as one big dream but
I'm so glad we met
[Music]
upon I know you know you can't hug
people
oh man I love the scene this was an
addition this scene almost didn't happen
um but we had some extra time on the day
that we were at this location so I was
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna write a goddamn
scene the day before and I did plug and
Bandit need a resolution exactly and and
that was deserve it I I realized like
Bandit did not have a resolution and to
be able to have that and see wug again
um not outside the capacity where it
won't shoot you in the face of seeing
like it's not all bad like that's the
thing it's not all bad and that's what I
really want people to know about these
stories uh these shows it's like it's
not all bad but it is serious but also
it's not serious that's the whole
concept of it is fun but also tells the
story I think that in the craziness of
this Multiverse you can have all of
those things some joyous what band is
talking about is like seeing some things
that she thought she lost you know with
when times weird and the universes are
weird like
kind of like what was happening in Dr
strange but in a less well-toeled way uh
just like you know there are some things
that you can have you know little
opportunities and and it's kind of My
Philosophy is like you know there's
always something that smile about you
know you like not always but you know
there it's just like your perspective on
the experiences that you're uh involved
in you know I I love seeing the Bandit
go from the manic nature in part one
towards the end of unable being unable
to process what's happening to now being
like hey roll with the punches
um you know this kind of wormholes are
my thing like you know I can kind of if
I embrace it I can kind of enjoy some
things that I never thought I'd get to
see again you know and then yeah and
then you know you get to hug wug up
pretty much also Wade blind again it's
also dark in here oh it's so hot in here
I am behind that door and every time the
camera looks away I literally jump out
from behind and I have to grab when like
uh this way and then duck out of the way
so he's at least facing the right
direction you can see him he Clips this
like you see right here you see you come
up here and just this pipe here was just
scalding hot long
but he goes for it and I thought he went
for it so very very good this this by
Jordan is genuine fear really
legitimately like Jordan is about to die
here
the cookies falling down the all the
things falling into the Wormhole last
minute Edition
okay what do you think song or lazy
scene
I mean lore wise this like this is
obviously more fun
is there that much lore in that scene
necessarily like I mean it's just I mean
no no I agree it's legally I think
I'll leave it I'll leave it to chat okay
okay
sorry very sleepy that's okay we're
almost I'm so bored you know God the
show it just keeps going and going it
really does doesn't it
that was always the funny thing is like
um when and look I get it totally 100
people going into this might have had
expectations that it would be like Heist
I knew that going into this I knew that
making this project and I knew that some
people would be disappointed that there
wasn't a hundred endings let me tell you
something
100 endings would get really boring and
also like the differences between them
is like it becomes Heist was cool in
that it was a contained fund experience
going more than that
I would have to write 30 different
stories to do that and it's not like I
don't want to tell 30 stories I had an
idea Heist worked because that was the
idea this idea exists in the format that
it is and it has to be told this because
it is a story about being trapped in the
consequences of choices already made and
the only way to get out is for things to
end the ending is the meaning of it the
ending isn't the end even though it is
the ending is the only way to Freedom
um and that's like that's like what it
was about so when it comes down to
like people enjoying this and being like
man I wish it was more Innings I totally
get that but also there's no functional
difference between it because uh with
Heist you get to an ending and you go
back to the beginning and you do it
again that's what it is all this does is
like you die you live you die you live
again it's the same functional thing and
I'm not trying to defend it because
they're different types of stories but
if you are looking at it from the eye of
like oh well this should be like Heist
you're missing out on the fun of what
this really represents allow yourself to
see something new because not only I
don't really want to do the same thing
over and over like you don't want to
tell the same
I don't know yeah you want to do
something you had this opportunity where
you had this like budget and to do an
interactive thing again and a space
thing a Multiverse and you had full
creative control where like you can try
something a little riskier frankly
absolutely a little different that you
hadn't seen before like in the genre
I don't know I think that this is this
is uh this show is a Triumph I think
this show stands up on its own compared
to any TV show uh but also people are
perfectly entitled their opinions they
can be your favorite like you can have
your favorite does not have to be the
most recent project yeah absolutely but
also do know that there is so much fun
[ __ ] in here there is this is packed to
the tits with fun scenes funny scenes
like I love every every freaking moment
of this like tell the story and I got I
actually got to tell a cohesive story
that had an end so many of my [ __ ] has
like uh endings that don't stick The
Landing but I loved seeing people watch
this and people look at it in the ending
and they feel it God they feel it they
really feel it like yeah my acting has
gotten better obviously but just like
the actual story itself wraps up it does
and it's like it's so satisfying to have
something I've I've had so many Landings
or endings that don't stick The Landing
you know who kill Markiplier didn't
stick The Landing like I wanted it to
um you know Wilford mother loving worse
it's so open-ended that there is no
answer and that's how I did it you know
Damien like it even that like trying to
like ham fist the darkiplier lore into
something that works after I kind of
screwed up the who killed Markiplier one
like trying to like work back to like
fix it yeah yeah instead of working
backwards this is the first one where I
can work forwards and it's like oh it's
so fun anyway this is just me talking
about it this is not nothing to do with
the Lord don't listen to anything I just
said uh right by Vu it's close ooh for
those of you who have not gone left I
would go left but we shall go right
muted
Schmo Yoho
[Music]
[Music]
space was so
cool
so cool
[Music]
but it won't even live in a memory
universe
[Music]
unspooled
so cruel
to be leaving with only a melody
it's so pretty
what a pity
there were billions and billions of
stories
and infinite infinite Stars
we did our best to hold it together
but now the scenes are all pulling apart
[Music]
so cool
but it won't even live in a memory
[Music]
is this one
away that I could change all that's been
wrecked rewrite the regrets let's leave
no stone unturned
let's stay bright till wherever
burned
so cool
so cool
so pretty
hey yes thank you for all the 10-year
wishes of course but yes this and the
last goodbye are on Spotify and iTunes
right now under the Gregory Brothers the
Gregory brothers so if you want to find
them support them play that every day
all of the other other songs that
they've done for you yeah exactly I
don't want to be free I don't want to be
free and what's the other one that we
love that we were listening to the other
day that we're like that doesn't get
enough credit oh uh I'm back I'm back
baby yeah baby I'm back Monroe I'm back
baby
I'm back I'm out of control I'm fat baby
yo that was stuck in a red for all that
was on launch day of part two was just
nothing but that so uh you can find both
of those
also like I I edited this video myself
we filmed this after back here at home
yeah we filmed this here actually
um and it this one
this one's really important because like
it really does I made this show
because I love space and and I wanted to
do it justice if I was going to do a
space show I wanted to do it right this
is why this is my most involved project
why it took the most effort and and it
deserved the most effort and this song
is representative of it because it comes
full circle I don't like to
not acknowledge the things that got me
to where I am today and space is so cool
as a song made by the Gregory Brothers
back in the day like five years ago now
uh right around when date came out that
just really really embodies like my love
of space and it was it was super cool to
hear and to evolve especially
considering this is like my 10-year
stream I've been doing this for 10 years
you know I I've come very far in terms
of a content creator and a filmmaker I
do fully believe with the lessons that I
learned from this my skill set is so
rounded out I could make uh a movie I
talked about this on the member maker
I laugh because every once in a while
I'll see a tweet that's like I'm so
proud of Mark he made a short film
and I'm like
this is seven hours okay
I can imagine 90 minutes God yeah no I
can't wait to be able to make it 99.
when I say like I I have made movies
this is three movies
um but like what I mean is like I could
make a movie as good as any Studio has
ever made I know I could I'm fully
confident in my ability to do it
technically and story-wise uh so if any
big Studio
give me money but
then complete creative
for the future
I feel like like this project like
really rounded out
your confidence in being able to do
something like that and also like it
seems so much
like like one of our favorite things to
do is like when we watch a movie is to
look up the budget hmm and to be like oh
God oh my God you can do it so much
cheaper like I got 50 million dollars
only [ __ ]
you got it if only but like you can
think of like now you know what you can
do with the budget like with a little
bit of money like you could make a short
film and you don't know how to write
cheaply like yeah that's the thing
filming in a couple weeks like not short
film a film that's the beautiful things
like I I right now we've been talking a
lot about me I want to learn Unreal
Engine five and and like do that sort of
stuff so if anybody out there is
learning Unreal Engine five I'm right
there with you you know I think that's a
great tool for filmmaking but also just
like rounding out your skill sets try
something new I'm probably gonna figure
out a project to work with unreal5 to
really get me to learn that's the best
way to learn anything just do pick a
project and do something that needs that
tool and then do that anyway really
proud of this really happy with this but
it's not over yet
all right
foreign
captain
so obviously we've transitioned
we're back in the diner at the end of
the universe
at the End of the Universe
um one of the funny things about the
scene is Phil the DP
lovely really talented loves his
beautiful lights makes everything look
really pretty that's why this chair
looks so pretty is because of his
lighting not only with set Direction all
of it combined but just like the
lighting really adds them out to it he
lit the scene originally and had a lot
of like broken staticky lights and stuff
like that and I came in and I went this
looks great
can you take all of it down
I saw his his soul just be like
crushmore like can you turn off that
light and those lights
and those lights and the two lights back
there because I wanted it to feel like
it was completely empty and only lit by
like the last Moon left in the universe
and that's what you get here if you'd
like to know something else really cool
about this Scene It was the very last
thing that we filmed yes it was just
made it very special it was extremely
special that was in the BTS too it's
like this is the last scene that we
filmed that is very poetic that it was
um here we had more pickup shots yeah
but anyway
captain
I was hoping you'd be back
it's gone real dark out there
I imagine that
this is probably the end
don't worry about not stopping me soon
I'm starting to realize that even though
we have an infinite choice
second of Our Lives
there's only a handful of it really
you know
it's funny
I don't know why I
I'm happy
I don't know any other way to explain it
content
with everything
being this close to an end finally an
end
and seeing you again
just I don't know
it's good
for a while there I
I felt like I was right back there again
living every single life again and again
nurse stopping
always moving forward
but now
it's gone
it's gone
everything has to end captain
doesn't matter how tight we hold on to
things
they're still I threw you through your
fingers
you always make mistakes you have to
and that's okay
I just wish I learned that soon
for what it's worth
I'm glad I got to share this adventure
with you
the captain pauses for a moment
taking in the emptiness of the once
bustling Diner
pondering the lives of all those who
must have passed through this place
it's hard to imagine
it was ever full to begin with
but it was once
and that's what matters
just like old times dear captain
yeah
anyway
no that was a really really cool scene
and I it just was a coincidence that it
was the last scene that we found Isaac
sort of made sure that it was I mean
maybe he did but also at the same time
it was it was really good like um
it's it's a it's about resolution you
know the story in a lot of ways is about
characters
owning their mistakes
and also not not hating themselves for
making them in the first place if if you
notice in this story there are no
villains
that's kind of a common theme and a lot
of things I make there are no villains
there there are no bad guys there are
people
that are willing to go to any length for
what they believe is right and that can
like lead them to do terrible things
like with this uh and engineer Mark like
trying to save the universe or old Mark
trying to do the same thing but they're
that's because they don't know they
don't have the full context of
everything
um and so like really like there are no
bad guys here everyone is looking for a
bad guy with actor Mark like he's not
lurking behind the curtain the talking
door
okay yeah well the talking door still
got you to the warp core and besides it
wasn't the real talking to her the
talking door was hidden in the corner
like let's not be Captain that's not me
that's not me the the door saying that's
not me was the one joke that the first
time I read the script I didn't think it
was
funny yeah yeah because it didn't trip
I didn't see the vision
that's one of those times where I'm glad
I said nothing because goddamn is it one
of the best jokes so funny it's so funny
that CG door Ah that's not me that's so
good I love it good stuff very fun if
you don't know what I'm talking about
you gotta yeah you gotta watch the show
should we step out of the room for the
don't moment should we let them have
there I might need to leave we might
need to leave right let me just let's
just step out and we'll come back when
it's time
I want to watch it
maybe I should step out no
time hi captain
sorry about that
couldn't afford to let you make another
mistake
funny thing to say after an eternity of
nothing but Second Chances
don't
you don't have to keep trying anymore
there's no time you know it was funny
it's like so many times I'm like haha I
know I know what they're gonna like I
know what they're gonna think other
times I'm just like
what I don't know how you didn't see it
I how did anybody see it the rest of us
what is it
I'm saying don't and I wasn't the only
person on set who had the same reaction
no
a super video Village like oh buddy
it's a little spicy I don't know I don't
know
I'm not saying that that should be your
takeaway from this scene I'm just saying
I understand why it happened don't
stuff do not
don't
don't do it the antsy all over again no
like I don't know I don't know they're
really weird
yeah Mac does the same thing when you go
to Reese button and he just doesn't say
don't you grab your hand if I should put
that in like I should edit that maybe I
just added like uh don't just make add
on his lips like I do meow don't
someone make that edit Matt grabbing
your end and just put my lips going
don't put over him going don't
yeah that'd be good
I'm anywhere
there again
fix the damage you caused I had a long
time to spend rebuilding this machine
you broke a long time
Too Many Lives
but I know now that this thing does more
than just make more balls
distance and time are the same thing
from different perspectives
different points
of and this machine didn't just Bridge a
tunnel through our universe it was
bridging all of them
and you destroyed it
I can't undo what you've done
not here anyway
at least not now
if I could go back if I could try again
if I could stop you before any of this
even started
what the hell does that means
you'll destroy everything again
there we go
let me go
I've been police I can fix this look I
don't know what you did and maybe you
didn't mean to but I
have to stop you I
know God I wish I thought of a fake hand
or something please
this is it this is the end of everything
everyone that ever existed is gonna get
wiped out unless you let me go
two
have to keep trying
Don't Let Go Don't hold on
all right
I can't have this idea beforehand this
but
if they want to see the ending
um yeah I mean
I've walked you through a lot of this
show
and I've walked you through a lot of
like what it is and I've talked a lot
about the themes of this and stuff like
that
uh what the show means to me how it's it
actually is a story of one person trying
to do what's right like many people
trying to do what's right The Core theme
that a lot of people don't understand is
that you are not the only one making
choices not just you as an individual
not just you as a collective Captain
other people in the story are making
choices
there's another scene uh like the other
side of the song where ladies in the
void and lady has a line there that says
I wonder what would have happened if I
didn't choose to follow you down that
damn wormhole
and that's because that is a choice
the lady made and lady did not have to
make that choice because if you go back
to part one at the end old Mark does not
recognize lady
and that's because in that version in
part zero lady did not choose
to follow you down that wormhole
it's a series of choices even here there
are multiverses where a lady did not do
that if lady was not in this show
pursuing you relentlessly can you
honestly say that you would be fully
informed to make the correct decision at
the end maybe maybe not
it's hard to say some of you yes some of
you no
I think uh
I think I've touched on just about
everything there are a few things that I
want to talk about
um
no villains I talked about that talk
about that okay the other thing that I
want to say is this show
while simultaneously
you know this may not be actor Mark this
may not be anything
but it provides an explanation for
everything that has or will happen in
previous stories
engineer Mark is not actor Mark
but actor Mark might just be engineer
mark
this might be the core basis of
everything that has happened echoing
backwards in time
because the story of this takes part in
the future
but in this in the in the Multiverse and
tearing it open with the Wormhole you
get an opportunity for all of these
other stories to fit into it because at
the very bottom of this chaotic swirling
Wormhole when everything is collapsing
down on itself
there's Mark and there's you
us together our Collective story which
is exactly representative of this
Channel and everything that I've made so
far it's you and me the collective you
and the one of me which is so weird
because the opposite is shown in all my
stories it's the multitude of me's and
the singular you but it's both are true
at the exact same time I'm one person
but you have an infinite number of
interpretations of who I am I'm one
person and there's an infinite number of
you guys out there to interpret you know
it's it's the duality of it it's kind of
the beauty of the creation creative
process on YouTube represented in a
story
it's
our dance you and me me taunting you
constantly me being an [ __ ] you
chasing after it you guys created darker
Blair I've said that before you made
darkiplier therefore in a weird way you
are darkiplier and they also influence
like the characters that they care about
people like antsy right that then sort
of help dictate the way that you write
the next project right like it is this
like symbiotic sort of relationship it
really is like I once said that who
killed Markiplier the void had a lot of
inspiration from like Warhammer 40K it's
universe but another way it's weirdly
similar to that is with Warhammer 40K
belief in something makes it real in
that other in the warp right so for you
guys your belief in these characters and
your love for them solidify their
reality in this fake reality this
sub-universe of my mind which is just
these shows are just Visions in my mind
made into reality reality it's still not
real but it's real enough we did it yeah
and that's kind of like blending the
line between
you and I creating at the same time
simultaneously I would not be here
without you guys I would also not be
here without the other YouTubers that
inspire me I would not be here without
Amy this show would not have been made
without Amy like me writing it you
helping guide the process of filming it
like all these small steps
like when you think about like all of
your friends being in your projects
um and like the way that if you talk to
anyone who spent any amount of time with
you they would describe you we use the
word tornado but I think Wormhole is
also an app description yeah yeah of
like the way that you sort of get sucked
in to your storytelling you're like once
you're in like you're stuck with me like
I'm gonna keep dragging you into
projects I said to Morgan it was like
get ready you're you're in here and as
soon as like you guys started making fan
art of the Bandit Morgan was like what
the hell that's you getting pulled into
the worm in the whirlpool wormhole
whatever that's what happens like you
you guys suck people into it because you
do love it and you do support it and you
tear it apart and you cherish it and you
make other works from it like I'm the
most proud I could possibly be is that
this inspires you to make something
anything it could be a piece of fan art
it could be a story it could be a
cosplay it could be another interactive
that's what we talked about with Heist
for you know people being like wishing
it was more like Heist to like in just a
way that it just branched out and you're
like well anyone can make that like
anyone yeah you guys can be nice too you
guys can make date that's what I I want
people to realize about this this is a
big production thing but you can't just
start with this because you need skills
to be able to do this like it's not me
being uh conceited to say that like you
can't do that if you're just starting
out like I'm warning you not to try
because yeah you will learn a lot but
you can see the journey that it's that
it's taken you yeah there's a fun path a
fun path of making projects that get
progressively better and enjoying the
ready to process the entire time instead
of like destroying yourself trying to
make something this big I would love
people to make date we made date cheap
the budget was like 10K okay that sounds
like a lot yeah that sounds like a lot
because you're paying the people I'm
paying the people yeah make it with your
friends you can make with your friends
for free let me rent in a couple of
locations we rented a couple locations
in in the grand scheme of Productions
comparatively that's cheap but even
before date came the free sketches that
we made like no money sketches it's a
progressive process to make a 24 video
series for that amount of money is in
the film World pretty crazy
um and even that was like kind of
amateurish uh you guys can make a Choose
Your Own Adventure in your room
with the right idea you can make
anything you got the tools to do it at
your just your iPhone camera is better
than the cameras we were using at the
time like exactly well maybe not well
maybe not better than that but
definitely when I started YouTube phones
today are just as good if not better
like it's crazy the tools that you have
and it doesn't even need to be like as
high quality as any of this it doesn't
need to look that way because YouTube is
an open platform for you to do whatever
you want that's the beauty of it there's
and there's stuff like the montages or
like the gyms where it's like yeah like
you could have like part of the charm is
that they're not perfect you know like
beautiful VFX shots like sometimes like
the jankiness is like the charm of it
the jangitus is like the puppet show and
that's what we always worried about
especially with Heist let's do this
because we knew it was okay but the
scariest thing going into Heist and one
of the reasons that people I think like
we're not receptive to YouTube Originals
projects is because like when people
watch YouTube they want it to feel like
the Creator made it and sometimes when a
Creator gets a bigger budget and they
have a some like a someone else
directing right they have other people
involved it loses that that charm yeah
but I'd like to think that these
projects have held on to that to a
degree
you know oh yeah because that's the
important part of YouTube in a weird way
I am sad that YouTube Originals is going
because I feel like I don't know I I
don't want to say like I had any sway in
YouTube Originals because obviously I
was not making YouTube Originals any
money like this listen this video did
not make its money back but in no way oh
no God no
um but what it did I think is show that
if there I am not the only Creator on
YouTube that can make a show that people
really like or want to devour or watch
or get really excited about that of
course not there's so many people that
could like they could do this or better
I'm sure they're out there like I've met
many of them but like I I think that
this
being a project that I had complete
creative control over to make something
that really elevated the content that I
make on a daily basis really kind of
showcases that to you guys and the
YouTube audience that hold like it can
be done and it can be done well that
honors the creators that are a part of
it and honors YouTube as a platform
itself but it's a relationship of trust
and I get that it's a business decision
to downsize YouTube Originals I can't
influence that at all or maybe I can but
I'm just happy that I had the chance to
do this because I'm not going to stop
making things
you know that I've been doing this for
10 years and I I now more than ever I
want to make stuff more than ever before
like it's kind of crazy it's uh it's
done such a wonderful
wonderful wonderful experience I cannot
explain
the feeling of satisfaction that you get
from making things it is wonderful and
you don't have to make something like
this first thing look at the fall of
Slenderman my first sketch with Wharf
stash my first sketch character
it's it's crap but I love it I do I do
love it that's like I think the best
thing about these projects that I felt
is like and stuff like Unison is too
like that I've been involved in
um is I have yet to like look back on
any of these and because you look back
on this you know in any of the past ones
and like like I can look on I'm just
honest and be like there are so many
things I do differently like there's so
many things I do better you know all
this stuff but I'm never looking back on
this with like frustration that they're
not better it's always more of like an
excitement that the next one could be
better yeah you know because like you
feel like you gain all these skills
every time you try it God I know it's
heresy but we've been watching simuna's
honest compilation don't tell anybody
I'm not telling anybody oh no I was just
like man it's good it's
to better mode
take them
hey it's ours we if anybody I'm not
it's um
yeah it's just an honor it is I want to
thank like all the crew that was part of
this like go through all the names of
the people in the credits really look at
them and understand that every single
one of those people dedicated hundreds
of hours of their life to make this
project a reality some of them thousands
it's beautiful the number of man hours
that go into this is nuts yeah there was
about 150 people in total that worked on
this and every day there'd be maybe 40
people on set 50 60 sometimes yeah lots
of people people making art and really
loving it along the way there is a world
where all of that can work I firmly
believe that and I am willing to put my
money where my mouth is to make that
world a reality if it's not going to
show itself so I want to thank like all
the crew all the cast like all the
lovely talented friends that I have that
dedicated their time their energy to
making an idea that I had a reality I am
not gonna make this last choice and I am
not going to talk about the ending
because if you have not seen it yet go
watch it and bring a friend along for
the ride legitimately set up time to
schedule a watch party with your friends
it's fun it's fun someone who has not
that's such an opportunity you have
someone that has not seen any of this
before you get to show them the insanity
that is the show let them make choices
about it that's fun like oh I think
that's fun anyway so definitely do that
and you will have to go see the ending
for yourself
um
like there are obviously some still open
questions uh that I could answer I will
probably answer them
eventually it'll come I don't think
you're never gonna talk about this again
God but what I'll say is like most
things in this story like I said the the
the story is the lore but there are some
doors that this opens backwards in time
and connects backwards
and the post-credit scene God no that is
not honest you clauds
how could you think that you found that
the sound the ringing the wood creaking
what is wrong with you it's darkiplier
literally saying the line from a heist
with markiplier with the sound cue from
heist with Markiplier
it links to a heist with markiplier what
more do you want don't look so deep into
it with the shoes
it's clear I mean this might have those
I think those were though those were
because it was the only shoes I've had
the only shoes I had you can't show the
whole suit and remember like why doesn't
he have a sleeve is he just sure he's
dark shirtless it's like no if you bend
over in a suit and you reach with your
arm the sleeve doesn't go all the way
with you
you idiots stop looking so deep it's
right in front of your face
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching
uh cloakbrand.com limited edition space
posters they are incredible there's a
paper version and a metal version
um and there's a bunch of other mugs
there if you want the other mug tweet at
cloakbrand uh make him not forget about
it it's like dumpster jumpsuits
jumpsuits yeah all kinds of stuff
um yeah thank you to burning tractor
post uh VFX for doing all that uh thank
you for TBD post oh TBD post I feel like
that's something like that you never
talked about that has been the last six
months of Our Lives yeah has been
post-production how many how many days
work days were we in Texas just for
sound purely for sound mixing five weeks
five weeks yeah over the last few months
five weeks we've been in Texas a lot
literally talking five
just four weeks living in a hotel like
not like we were in Texas a week and we
worked two days no five full weeks
of just sound mixing yeah yeah
um yeah thank you guys
um this this VOD will be posted you can
tear it apart uh as much as you want I
encourage you to go watch the show
um people who keep asking about this
weird mask I don't know what you're
talking about people are saying the same
thing at the end of Wilford mother
living worship they kept asking about a
mask I have no idea what this is I've
heard a lot about a train too yeah I
don't know what that's talking about
um I will try to look into that I've
literally no idea what you're talking
about in terms of a mask or anything
like that
um but yeah normal videos will start up
in about one week next Monday we will be
back to normal videos I'm taking a month
or a week off not a month off I'll take
a month no I'm taking a week off and
then we will be back to normal videos
coming at you hot and fresh thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
all have a wonderful day go watch part
two if you haven't already go find a
friend watch part one again and thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you Amy for being a part of this you're
welcome excited to make more stuff in
the future me too so we'll see you soon
thanks for watching yep it's Marathon
look at this right at 5 p.m 6 p.m what
time is it
goodbye goodbye